what is up people how you guys doing
welcome to the podcast
so this one this episode is such a treat
especially for all you creators out
there because today's guest
a beautiful soul one of my very
favorite visionaries of the image both
still and moving
is none other than chris burkhart chris
is just so many things he's a
photographer an
artist an adventurer a world traveler a
filmmaker
an endurance athlete a surfer father man
of faith all of which is to say that he
is first and foremost a storyteller
a storyteller best known for his
photojournalistic
humanizing approach to man's
relationship with nature
across a multitude of media i've been a
huge fan of this guy for ages
and this conversation was very long in
the making it does not disappoint
and it's really a glimpse into the
creative mind of
a true artist laced with potent life
lessons that i think are going to leave
you
thinking more broadly about your own
path at least that's the intention
if you're digging my stuff and this
channel please take a second to hit that
subscribe button
and the little notification bell so
you're properly alerted every time we
drop a new video
i appreciate that and i appreciate chris
i love this guy one of my favorite
people so let's do it this is me
and chris burkard
[Music]
so part of my grand vision for 2020 yeah
which is laughable now is this plan i
had to take the podcast on the road and
do this multi-city tour
and part of that vision was doing a live
event with you and me
on stage at the palace of fine arts in
san francisco
yeah this is not happening in 2020. so
here we are today instead this is a long
time coming but
if there's any kind of um comfort
uh in doing this one-on-one as opposed
to on stage we actually have an audience
here today
i've never had an audience for a podcast
i love it i've interviewed lots of
amazing people
but you definitely pulled a crowd today
so we actually have people here to
witness this happenings
i'm a little nervous my wife is here to
make sure i don't say anything stupid
which is excellent
so yeah we're not live streaming no you
can edit it out
if you want but uh look man um
i'm really delighted to meet you i've
been a fan
for a long time have so much respect for
your work
not just your work but like how you live
your life how you comport yourself
um i'm excited to unpack all of it
man and i've also said this before with
people who
have you know a social media presence
there is that sense that you feel like
you know somebody
um i definitely have that with you but
it's different
i do feel like a level of connectedness
to you that i
don't have with other people even though
we've never met and i think that speaks
to
what i think is your greatest talent
which is that you're a storyteller
you're always telling stories
and you do it in a way that that is
really brings people
into your experiences and makes them
feel like they're right alongside with
you
that means a lot i mean that's that's
really the goal i mean if there's a way
to
compromise this entire life story into
one
sentence it's that i really want to tell
meaningful stories
and it's a funny thing not to dive
straight in but
that started with just my immediate
family my mom my dad
right and then and then evolved now to
millions of people but the reality is
like the
i think the the effort and the intimacy
is the same like
i oftentimes you know and it can be at
fault for wanting to share
too much because i because i just really
enjoy
bringing people into what that
experience is like and being honest and
real
as much as you can in this day and age
well there's a tension there because
everything that you're about is about
being present in the moment
and and really immersing yourself in the
environments that you're in
but to share that is to take you out of
that experience right right so how do
you like
wrestle with that aspect of what you do
that's so hard there's boundaries that i
think
life creates um in just in general with
how we
how much we can share how much it's it's
available to people you know and then
you have this whole you know kind of i
think issue nowadays of like the
relatability
and people understanding you and
everything's got to be so
like you know synthesized down to like
very straightforward
terms and how you say it because you
don't want to you know offend anybody
nowadays but there's a rawness and a
realness to i think
bring people out on the road and and um
and bringing people with me into those
experiences
and and i think if anything i i've i've
really relied upon
my wife as a guiding source of of that
and and also
i think just understanding that you know
and this is a funny thing because i to
be honest i kind of hate talking about
social media in many ways
i've always seen it but i also love it
right so i've always seen it as
all it is is a glorified texting
platform
and you have this beautiful opportunity
to get to know the people that you're
communicating with
you know it's not this thing where
you're just opening the door to
someone's house
blurting out a message then before they
have the chance to come to the door you
just close it right like
there's this reciprocation and so i feel
more than maybe most really tuned into
like the needs the questions the ideas
what they want to see and then
a lot of times that can in many ways
direct
um almost like the projects the stories
the things i want to tell i i
i can adhere to the needs of of young
parents because
i'm a young parent and it's a scary
thing and it terrifies me every day and
then making films or
books or whatever that can address these
things or
addressing climate or environmental
issues but through my lens
i guess kind of to get back to the core
of that question i feel like
learning to listen to what the needs of
this audience is because that's really
who you're serving right like as a
person who's putting work into the world
you're trying to serve a
broad group of people and obviously you
can't do it perfectly but you're trying
to kind of tune into those who really
understand you
but it still requires a strong sense of
self
and you know an antenna that's finely
tuned to who you
are so that you're maintaining that
level of authenticity because
if you're canvassing the input from this
massive audience of millions of people
you can become
distracted trying to please them or
fulfill whatever their
need or desire is as opposed to
following your own
muse and that's what got you to this
place yeah and that's a scary thing
because i think we evolve as people and
our interests evolve and
and sometimes i had this real fear early
in my career i remember
um this seems so untrivial now but like
i was you know
early 20s and i was working on staff for
surf magazines that was all i knew all i
understood was surfing because that was
my bread and butter growing up
and i remember kind of detaching myself
from that world that career path
a bit and being really concerned that
like oh my gosh if
if i stop you know shooting for the
magazines and making surf films and
and start kind of pursuing some of my
other passions which was more pure
landscape or
i guess storytelling on a deeper level
addressing you know environmental issues
and all these things
i'm like are these is this audience or
people that engage with me or
clients or buy my prints or whatever are
they gonna like
detach or not care and i i was so
fearful and i kind of realized like
at a certain point i'm like what what
would i be doing i would be doing
something untruthful i'd be pursuing a
path that was just
unrealistic and and dishonest and i i
kind of had to take that leap and yeah
it resulted in
in a big change in my career path and
ultimately i'm
so much happier because what i ended up
pursuing
was so in line with what i cared about
and what i loved and that's been a
constant theme taking that leap and and
this is the
funniest thing because we address risk
in so many different ways
and one of the things i realize is that
what has become risky to me
or what is risky to one individual it's
all perspective right it's all
how much time you've put into that and
at a certain point
the idea of photography or sharing
stories or
kind of opening up your life that
becomes commonplace and not as scary and
then all of a sudden
as a creative person you know we we love
to use this
terminology of like get outside your
comfort zone but what does that actually
mean when you
when you've kind of gotten to a place
where that's second nature so
you have to pursue that next level like
what is that is that
is that public speaking is that standing
up in front of the icelandic government
and speaking on behalf of the river
systems as an outsider
most terrifying experience of my entire
life
there are kind of things i've tried to
pursue to realize that
in order to achieve that growth that i
want in order to be that example to my
kids and
i have to pursue those places of
discomfort
and even now in 2020 it's like you can
find discomfort and
anywhere you go even wearing a mask um
you know can be
uncomfortable or politicized or whatever
or speaking up for the things that you
believe in and
and i just feel like that's the type of
person that i
aim to be and that's type person i i
hope to inspire others to to be worried
to explore like riding your bike around
yeah which we're going to talk about
you know it is interesting how you
acclimate to
a certain level of discomfort until it's
comfortable because
you know when you look back over the
course of your career and we're going to
get into that
you know it's a ballsy thing to kind of
shirk a more traditional path and say
i'm going to become
a surf photographer but then you achieve
a certain level of
of acumen and success with that to the
outsider looking in
that looks like a super adventurous
career but then it becomes normalized to
the extent
where it becomes easy and you're not
pushing yourself anymore
you're absolutely right and this was
actually the theme
of my my ted talk when i was able to be
given the incredible
terrifying coming-of-age experience of
speaking on the ted global stage
you rocked it though it was it was
honestly she looked very comfortable up
there
well yeah it was next level i mean the
the amount of stress that i endured
prior to that i revised my talk 17
times um i went through so many
iterations i remember i would like be in
the shower repeating it to myself on the
treadmill i like remember taking advice
from like beyonce like if you can't
sing your song while running on the
treadmill you shouldn't do it like just
stupid things that
that happened and um the story just go
on but i tried to get to a place where
it was so second nature that i felt like
i
could deliver it with the utmost energy
and
and realness that i could bring to it
but
point being was that that talk was
really addressing this idea of
having a dream job kind of amidst
all odds and then realizing once in that
dream job
that this wasn't what it was cracked up
to be like that
i was on these remote beautiful beaches
that i had seen in the pages of
magazines dreaming as a kid
and then i get there and i'm really just
selling this false sense of adventure
there's a high-rise hotel and great
wi-fi and
amazing food and not that those are bad
things but as somebody who
thought as a young kid who never
traveled anywhere and never owned a
passport never went
outside the u.s that i was going to find
this sense of adventure i
i and i wasn't finding it i realized
that there was kind of this
as i coined it sort of this crusade
against the mundane and the point
being and i think why it became relevant
to other
um you know sort of fortune 500s that i
spoke for and and carried on that talk
was that any career can do that any any
career path and so to
find what it is that inspires you and
motivates you
even if it's kind of pursuing something
different um
very different at the times for me it
took me from the beaches of australia to
like the remote you know shores of
iceland
that that's really what it was and i was
it was a terrifying
time in my life and those decisions
still kind of i look back on thinking
how in the world
did i decide to to do that you know so
yeah
the line that really stuck out for me
and the whole ted talk i know it's not
your line but i think it's so
true and poetic is pain is a shortcut to
mindfulness
right brock bastian i believe that was
his am
an incredible psychologist who studied
pain it might even been somebody else
but he was a big component of somebody
that i
i looked into and it's funny how these
you know i'm sure you've had this or
you've had these kind of keynote
presentation things where
it leads you down this path and you
learn something about something and
you're like oh my gosh like
through this process i learned so much
about me and why i did
what i did and this is something i feel
like you
can relate to extremely but this idea
that that
pain is is a shortcut to mindfulness
what does that mean when you unpack it
like
the more sort of painful experiences we
endure and this doesn't mean like i
stubbed my toe or i'm hurting myself but
but sorrow sadness even
times where you're really just giving a
150 of what you have to offer and
and it's it's can be challenging you
remember those things more that was his
whole point was that these stick with
you that the memory is
is cut deeper and he even did incredible
studies where
had groups people that would like that
had endured something
challenging together and then groups
people that didn't and had put like
scented water in front of them and they
could pick up the scent
more why because their senses were more
attuned so
you envision you're in you know i don't
i can only imagine
rich like you know mile 100 of you know
the ultraman or something like that
riding the bike and everything's just
kind of getting really visceral
like the smell the road your vision
everything sharpens it's like this
incredible acuteness that becomes really
honed in and
i think this is why we kind of both
enjoy that endurance
aspect because the longer you endure the
more
you feel and so that was a really unique
thing to kind of
i think come to the realization that
these cold environments these harsh
environments these freezing environments
that
seem so inhospitable we're actually
providing me
and anybody that goes there with a more
um
incredibly rich experience yeah there's
something about
having to earn it too yeah that gives it
greater meaning and resonance in your
life and
you know when i think of you as a
storyteller i think of somebody who
who who makes art out of man's
relationship with
suffering and these inhospitable
environments and in the context of
surfing
we think of surfing and it's it's sort
of inextricably linked with tropical
environments right there's waves all
over the world
exactly and you kind of arrive at this
place of let's explore the waves that
nobody's looking at let's go to these
places where there's incredible surf
where nobody's ever photographed these
places before
i think a part of that journey was to
try and find myself and who i was and
what i was looking
for i think that was really the the
deeper deeper more
untold perspective of that was like
and maybe in some ways i was running
from something or i was looking to
punish myself but i think there's
something about the fact that you're
hoping to
go to these far ends of the earth and
and learn something about who you are
and about your process that's really
powerful as a young person man woman
whatever just to
just to kind of see what's out there and
i and i what i found in those places was
i think a true sense of what i was
willing to commit myself to
and that felt really empowering as a as
a young kid yeah i guess
well i want to trace this back to its
origins but but why don't we start first
with iceland i mean what is this love
affair
that you have with iceland have you been
no i've never been
okay well you should first of all go and
if you do please
reach out to me uh-huh because i would
be so don't think i'm gonna go to
iceland without calling you first yeah i
mean making sure i'm all hooked up you
have to i mean the the first thing you
need to
do is is go there and run the the lag of
our trail i believe that's how you say
it
is that the 50 miler that you just did
yeah it's a really popular
um they do an ultra marathon that goes
from landmark lager to thor's mark and
it's like
basically the two of the most beautiful
places in the entire country it's
the most gorgeous trail it's one of like
you know national geographic's top 50
hikes and
i sadly after 43 trips had never done it
and oddly enough at the end of this
incredibly amazing bike trip i was like
there's a great weather window
this would be a smart idea to maybe go
and uh
and do it like totally unprepared
totally untrained i just rode my bike
all the way across the middle of iceland
but i think i need to go
run 50 miles before i leave and let's be
let's be honest it was more of like
it started as a jog and then turned into
like a
painful walk but so beautiful and so
immersive and you're walking through
steam vents and you're moving across
snow and
and then you're moving in between two
major glaciers one of the most
active or the most recently active
eruptions af yataliyoko
you move between where that erupted in
this
beautiful like just monochromatic almost
landscape where there's there's glacier
and then there's
lava flowing out it was surreal so
beautiful
um and so yes anyways if you go let me
know
there's so many people i'd love to
connect you to and and uh
and whatnot but what is it about iceland
that stays
with you so a part of me i've actually
thought about this a lot i kind of
thought about this before the show
too and it's been asked quite a bit of
me and
sometimes i think maybe it's just so
different than what i grew up with
you know the the kind of now desert of
california
and i live in central california pismo
beach
it's where i was born that's where i was
raised um it's a cool mediterranean
climate but we don't have seasons
you know what i mean like it rains kind
of um
it gets a little chilly but we don't
have these real seasons and we
definitely don't have the geothermal
activity and i think a big part of it
was that i went there during this
it was 2006 when i went there you know
um
kind of right before its first big
tourism boom and
and my experience was so um
influential in my life in my career and
just so
unique to me that i felt something
different than i had ever experienced
anywhere else and it
it kind of spurred you know the next
trip and i just kept
trying to find jobs to go there you know
my first trip there to iceland was for
men's journal i was documenting
timmy turner he's a surfer that had um a
staph infection in his brain from
surfing in warm water
sorry this is a long story made short
and i went there to document him surfing
in cold water which was what his doctor
approved so it was kind of this
this place in person story about
about this athlete and it was a really
cool experience and we went
all over the country and i remember just
coming home
and kind of trying to process all that
realizing like i just been somewhere
truly unique
truly remote like we moved our way
through giant icebergs on the beach like
a maze to get to the ocean i just
that amount of kind of sacrifice and and
felt really really stuck with me like it
like a
i don't know almost like a rash or
something like that and i couldn't get
the itch away and i just
started to look for excuses to go back
and then there was also kind of a
business element to it as well where
when you really
dial a place in you become sort of i
guess in some ways a go-to person so
um production teams and whatnot were
coming to me asking me like okay well
how could we do this and do you know
this person and i
i sort of um tried to i guess
provide as many opportunities to create
work there and that
that became kind of a love affair with
the place and ultimately
after like trip number six seven eight
nine ten whatever it became
will the people are what are bringing me
back friendships
this landscape there were environmental
issues and to fully steal a quote
directly from yvonne chenard you know
you you can only spend so much time
in these wild places before you feel a
sense of responsibility to want to
protect them and that
ultimately became the mission it was
like get there at all
at all costs possible because there is
work to do
and these beautiful gorgeous river
systems
that i had documented and experienced
and moved through
were in real threat of danger from
aluminum smelters and
dams being built and i wanted to lend my
voice to that
and so that has really over the last
seven years became the mission and
um as my wife knows i'm not much for
vacation so
every trip there be was like how can i
weasel my way into work or do a job
but then find time to work on my own
project
including this new film right now how do
you say it yeah
yeah yeah so a new film that's um it's
touring in festivals right now thank you
so much
tribeca right yeah premiere to tribeca
went to mountain film it did the rounds
it was a really
hard year because i was so excited to
bring the cast and the crew and my
icelandic friends
to new york to like experience this and
to really have this coming-of-age story
and ultimately you know to give kind of
people the the preface this film is
actually going to be premiering online
on the 22nd of september and um
it'll be out there kind of for the
masses after that but
the goal was to really in the evolution
of storytelling in my own experience you
know sometimes i guess you could say
it's easier to tell stories about things
that you're going through through
someone else's lens so as much as i
i care and i love um ellie and his
experience i know that i've got my own
fears
of parenting and risk and and the reward
of what it's like to raise kids in a
wild environment and through his
his honest portrayal of his basically
near-death experience i'm able to
share with the world what i think is is
potentially a way maybe the right way to
raise kids and
i know that's something that you've
dealt with as well and it's just been a
yeah
yeah it's it's beautiful and compelling
and essentially it's a narrative
of this father-daughter relationship
and his desire um and struggle with how
to raise his daughter in a more
naturalistic environment
in the modern world like even though
they're in iceland they're still the
city he makes this choice to live
outside of that he has this near-death
experience
and he's trying to impart you know in
his daughter
this connection with the natural
environment that is so meaningful to him
and keep her like pure in that regard
it's almost like
um you know that movie and that tv
series hannah yeah
it's sort of like hannah but in a in a
more yeah
a less aggressive way yeah without all
the terrorism and all the other stuff
right
but and in many ways i think the cool
thing is like he has sort of this
extreme example
um and allie's a dear friend like
somebody who really like my experience
of that place of iceland
and anywhere i've been has always gone
to the
degree when you finally meet a local or
people that can like
show you the way and my connection to um
locals and all these environments that
go to so important like
that has opened up the place to me in a
way that just never could have before
and him being willing
to share that story was so meaningful
but also scary like as
as a storyteller one of the biggest
fears you have is like working with your
friends you hear this all the time like
don't work with your friends
you know and and when i kind of got
this story from him and he told me
i was shocked i was like wait you you
[Music]
kayaked down a river you got caught
behind a waterfall
for 40 minutes we're going hypothermic
and you literally tried to penetrate
through the waterfall over and over and
blacked out and they just found you down
the river
and one of the craziest experiences it's
so hard talking about a film people
haven't seen it because you're kind of
like giving it away but you're also like
giving people a thing but when we were
filming this
this project and it's a short film it's
only 17 minutes right
we were filming this project we got to
academy in the north of iceland we went
to the waterfall
i can't express how significant it is
to witness healing happen
right i mean we're there he hadn't been
there in 12 years
like he hadn't been there since it
happened and we're walking over he's
like yeah he's like that's where they
found me
and like this is where the waterfall is
and we're kind of walking through this
and we get out of our car and we're
packing up our stuff and there's a
farmer that drives by
and ellie waves to him you know like you
do in icelandic and
all of a sudden the farmer and him are
talking in icelandic and i see them kind
of like
getting closer and closer and talking
more and the farmers
basically ellie told me he's like yeah
this guy's lived on this road his whole
life and he
fully remembers that experience and i
can't remember if he was even involved
and like
the one who called sort of the ambulance
in acutery or something like that but i
was just
it was just so powerful and so
significant and to
to use storytelling as a tool to
allow people people you love people you
care about to
relive experiences and deal with
experiences and
find in some ways that closure is
so powerful makes me emotional just
thinking about it well
what's fascinating is that
is that you you provided that from a
western perspective
like the footnote to the story is that
you know his friends find him a half an
hour later or whatever
and they get him out of there and they
never speak of it again
and implied is that he never spoke about
it again and you just move on in this
like
icelandic nordic viking stoic
you know way of how you conduct yourself
as a man
yeah but clearly he's carrying that with
him and it's only
someone like yourself who comes in who
is raised you know in a different way
with how we process our emotions that
could provide him
a comfortable way to you know move to
the other side of that and it's a funny
thing because i maybe i have the
tendency of being too emotional just
being like dude like how like how have
you
not dealt with this i'm like i'm crying
now like and it was just such a unique
thing
but that's that's what friendship is
about like that's why
i think we we dive into these stories to
to kind of meet each other halfway and
find find areas to kind of i think work
on and improve it
it was a wild experience and i love that
so yeah cool
well i want to talk about the bike stuff
but let's go back to the let's go to the
beginning
jumping on all these subjects no it's
cool um
raised by a single mom who had you when
you were when she was 17.
yeah yeah um
what can i say about that i um it's such
a
a weird thing to kind of in some ways
put out there because it's such a
personal part of who i am and
and um i've i've you know at my mom's um
you know willingness to share kind of
been been able to i think
you know in some ways open up about that
a bit but
in reality i witnessed you know the
struggle
the harsh realities of of what it's like
to to grow up in a single parent home
and
my my dad passed away before i was born
so there was never this abandonment
scenario but i
realized very clearly and very quickly
just how much effort was put into like
trying to raise a kid and i think that
it's changed my views on kind of
everything as i've come of age in the
beginning you don't really understand it
but as you
become those ages of 12 15 and you know
18 you
you start to recognize like oh well you
know we didn't travel because that
wasn't on the table and i can't go to
college because there wasn't that
opportunity there
and uh the sacrifices that were made
were so significant at the time that i
just i couldn't fully fathom it you know
i was more worried about like
when we were gonna get you know burger
king as a kid or something like that not
that like
my mom was like cleaning houses and
managing a gym and
not only did i witness this you know
awesome example of somebody who was
totally sacrificing everything but also
she had
like good jobs like she was the manager
of a gym and she was just this
this awesome kind of badass lady and so
in many ways
that example for me has just given me
sort of the
zero excuse policy of like i
have always dealt in some capacity with
a personality trait that just wants to
prove
um that i'm worth it because i know she
made incredible sacrifices i mean not
going to senior prom because you're
you have a one-year-old is pretty real
and i
i think that's always been a part of my
story is like
and not really the one that i want to
always start with but it's like it's a
part of who i am is like i've
i've worked so hard and maybe in some
ways i've i've gone ahead
strong into suffering because i've felt
the need to prove
to her and maybe to others that i was
worth it and that this this sacrifice is
worth it so yeah it's
something i'm dealing with still i mean
you know i suspect that it gave you a
strong sense of
of you know resilience and this idea
that you know nothing
you can't take anything for granted and
if you want to make your way in the
world you're going to have to work for
it because
everything is earned absolutely yeah i
mean you nailed it and even
just the idea that like life in general
like i
there was many opportunities for her to
not have a kid
and she decided to do that i mean i
cannot imagine
you're 16 years old you're pregnant your
boyfriend my dad dies in a car accident
and all of a sudden you're like i'm
gonna
keep this baby and like that's a gnarly
decision to make and i just felt but
also a lot for
a young child to bear right that's an
overwhelming
you know yeah yeah idea to carry around
with you
it's hard to even process like when i
think about her now i'm like i can't i
don't
i can't even imagine the strength it
took to do that so when i when i've gone
on trips and i've been in those harsh
places i
that is a a fuel source so to say
that i've tried to rely on at times
thinking of like what she went through
and what i'm willing to go through for
what i care about so when you're in
elementary school and junior high do you
feel a sense of separateness from the
other kids because of this or
yeah um i was you know as lucky to have
an awesome stepdad step into my life uh
around like 12 13 and so that was really
awesome but there was still a sense of
detachment of like who i was and
you know just like you it's a weird
thing
not knowing where some of your character
traits come from um not understanding
that and i think
becoming a dad that's where it became
really hard
and i can tell you know
to be totally transparent because
you don't know how to treat young kids
you don't know what that felt like you
never had the dad to pat you on the back
or whatever like or to throw a ball
around or whatever
cliche tv dads do i don't know that's
all i knew so it was like
i had my mom and she was everything
all at once and and to not fully know
like when my kids were in these early
ages
i definitely i ran in some ways from
some of my
problems or my issues through traveling
and through dealing with that and i
think it was only
you know in the last like you know a
couple years i've
really tried to hone in on like how i
can
be the father that i want to be and i'm
not saying that i like
shirked off responsibility but i would
say that in many ways i just didn't have
the example
of what it should feel like or what it
should be like and not to say that there
is some perfect example because we live
in a crazy world and
everybody's given different
circumstances but for me
that's always been the hardest thing is
my relationship with work you know
as at times somebody's been a
self-professed workaholic like
it it can be the best thing in the world
or it can be a really hard thing because
you can bury your head into it and just
make it
sort of i don't know you can make it be
something that like really
covers up a lot of other ugly parts of
your life yeah i mean when
somebody like yourself who who you know
your disposition is adventure
and wanderlust is part of who you are
and makes you who you are and gives you
that
sustenance like it's it's a necessary
thing
you have to go out into the wild right
or you can't be your best self but you
can also
weaponize that and hide behind it yeah
um
and then it becomes more like a
pathology i had um
that's perfectly you know uh michael
muller
i i know of his work really i mean the
work he's done with sharks and
everything
it's incredible right so he was here
yesterday no way he we talked about the
exact same thing you know
i mean he's got two daughters and you
know reckoning with
with that and how to be a present and
healthy dad
with the need for adventure and how do
those things coexist in a healthy way
and i love that we're kind of coming
full circle here because
the point being is like my way of
dealing with it is
through storytelling and that's kind of
why i made this film to hope
that some parents out there dads moms
whatever can
understand that like there are answers
and there are people struggling and this
is
one way to look at it and yeah i had
certain sort of not traumatic but
experiences in my life that
that gave me perspective and i'm just
sort of dealing with that now and
it's kind of why i wrote a children's
book i wanted to address certain things
for my kids that i knew that
my my current books or films couldn't do
you know and
and i'm just looking for ways to to
communicate to them
um what's important right yeah cool
all right so when does the camera enter
the picture
right around 18 years old um i was
actually a full
just grease head in high school like i
worked on cars i was all i cared about
was automobiles um
and that was like my passion was like
custom cars custom cars that's it i
um and then i i started surfing a lot
with friends
um through the later years of high
school and that became like kind of
ditching class to go to the beach and
and i think this is a funny scenario
to sort of um but it was a little more
gang mentality it was
like you know my mom was finally taken
care of
by my stepdad and so me as sort of the
caretaker
or self-professed self-proclaimed
caretaker could kind of like
live your life step out of the picture
and i got into some trouble in high
school a little bit and it just led to a
lot of
um sort of undue stress and pain
whatever but
a part of that maybe was like you know
for me
going surfing and going with friends up
the coast and exploring big sur
and the northern reaches of slo county
it was like
i was finding my own and in some way
fitting in with this group and i think
part of that process was like
documentarian that was me like
i could come and document this and that
and this party and these things and
ultimately
photography it sort of dawned on me that
this like tool
um could be maybe more than just
a fun experience with friends but maybe
this could like
get me out of this small town maybe this
could be my passport to travel
maybe this could be a lot of things and
i i
i sort of digested that a bit more a bit
more and i was
going to junior college 19 years old
working
some terrible job at a magazine store in
pismo beach
and i told myself i'm like i'm gonna
give this five years
if i'm face down in the dirt somewhere
so be it if i'm thriving amazing but i
owe it to myself to see if photography
can be a career path and that's exactly
what i did and yes
i had delusions of grandeur that this
was going to be this amazing tool for
wanderlust but i also was very much like
egocentric in the fact that i just
wanted to earn money
as a photographer and so it was kind of
like pride
but maybe maybe the ego was even
stripped from it because i was like i
would shoot anything i would do anything
i would
you know i remember the very next day
after i quit my job at esquire news in
pismo beach
um it feels like yesterday i i was back
down at pismo beach back down at the
pier where i kind of
spent most of my time on the pier
looking out seeing people surfing and i
was literally taking photos of them
and then running up to them on the beach
and then being like hey like totally out
of breath i'll sell you this photo
uh of you surfing for like 20 bucks on a
cd and that was like that was how i put
gas in my car
um and uh and it was like you know again
senior picture
anything i could do i just the i tried
to kind of
understand that like if i could prove
anything to my parents who at the time
were like
you need to go to college you need to do
this and and i was like i don't really
want to go to junior college and learn
something i'm not going to apply
um i felt like i needed to prove to them
so from the beginning
it's always been proving myself and i
hate to say that because it sounds like
we're in sort of like a therapy session
which is fine but but
um but that's kind of sometimes what
this podcast is a little bit but but
yeah it was it was kind of
built around that like it was it was
about proving that right proving
yourself but also
wouldn't it be in part this this need or
this desire
to uh honor like your mom like who who
sacrificed so much
i'm sure she's thinking like this guy's
got to go to college after everything
that i did and yeah you to pivot and go
the other direction
there's an intensity to that like you
better make this work or
what was all of that for and i can
remember these vivid conversations
around the dinner table like
yelling matches where it was like you
you know you're the first person in our
family who can like go to college
because you had
good grades and you had scholarships and
i was like
i don't know how to tell you this but
i'm not going to school and like i'm
going to quit school and that was like a
i mean to be honest that was like that
was like the hardest thing i could ever
tell somebody that i respected and loved
so much was was that and this was a huge
point of contention and there were these
moments i mean
as anybody experiences at 18 like there
were these moments of very
real like raw emotion that were kind of
going back and forth and i and it kind
of marked a period in my life where i
sort of
i guess didn't dissent from the family
but i
moved into my car and was basically
living
in the back of my toyota tacoma and uh
you know
kind of like scraping pennies from the
floor of my vehicle
and like spending like a lot of time at
my girlfriend's house who's my now wife
so i don't feel too bad about all the
money i borrowed from her and her
parents too
uh for gas and other things but it was i
sort of dissented because i
i felt like i couldn't show
my face around them until i had
something worth showing a little bit
so but it was weird i mean there's a
there's an evolution that takes place
and i know we can
touch on this later but i think
everybody in some capacity nobody at 19
starts their career being like i'm going
to be
you know an environmentalist i want to
be a philanthropist and i'm going to be
all these
amazing awesome things to the world like
for me it was like i want to collect
stamps my passport and i want to get a
paycheck
and that's all i care about creativity
was awesome but
if that that wasn't the focus and and i
think
offering up deep meaningful work to
other people was kind of like
yeah maybe but it was all about just
like proving that this was a career
that was worth doing as opposed to going
to school
the origin is very cinematic and kind of
hilarious like i'm trying to picture you
in this magazine shop
surrounded by the covers of magazines
right like it's just like this is
messaging you
like the whole time it was kind of a
joke to be honest i'm sitting there
behind the counter
i'm eating red vines and then there was
like those really really
good coconut mexican popsicles like in
the in the corner and i'd be like
consuming those most of the day
over to my left right here was all like
the nudie magazines
right and then in front of that was like
all the adventure and travel magazines
so i would sit there all day and look at
the pages of national geographic
and afar and outside and kind of
daydream about like
looking at these places and in some way
i i honestly took that job
because i thought two things first of
all being close to the beach would be
an advantage for what i wanted to do in
my career and secondly because i could
always check the surf and this and that
um and i could like shoot before because
i was at the time i was already kind of
invested and involved in trying to
shoot surfing but all of a sudden i was
also like well i can also be like
studying what the magazines are printing
and publishing and
researching and maybe looking for
contacts and like i thought in some way
it would get me closer
right this grandiose it's sort of like
being yeah uh like working the
concessions at the movie theater
when you want to be a filmmaker exactly
and it's but but how
funny that we do that like we convince
ourselves we have these delusions of
grandeur it was
it was crazy there's an osmosis with
that like you're absorbing all of this
and on some level
it's feeding perhaps a fantasy of what
your life could be
but you need that in order to create a
foundation
and a core belief that that might be
possible for yourself like that
daydreaming process
i think is is important and
you see it played out in your life and
yeah i call her you're
you're spot on and one thing i've really
adopted from
um listening to some of your podcasts
was one in particular that was on
kind of the importance of boredom and
and
talking about how like this idea of
creativity we don't allow ourselves to
have anymore because
we're so filled up with our black
mirrors and our phones and our this and
there's always something to synthesize
us and like get us
kind of engaged and get that dopamine
hit and when you're sitting there
for four or five hours there's nothing
else to do but just kind of like flip
through the pages of a magazine
and daydream it does create
a sense of um romanticism around this
idea of a career path that i think in
many ways
kind of exploded in my mind you know
it's like oh maybe you could do this
maybe this could be you blah blah blah
and that that actually could have played
i mean i'm just diving this now that
could have played a huge part in why i
was so headstrong into like
i'm going for it you know so was there a
moment where
it clicked for you and you felt like
okay this is gonna happen like how did
it unfold
you know this is the the funniest
question
um that i've had a lot of times in
phrase in a little different ways like
was there like a
was there that big great turning point
in your career and and to be honest
there was there's never been a turning
point there's there's
been glimpses but what the funniest
thing is is that
for me those i guess you you could call
them turning points it's often when i've
moved past it and then looked back and
realized oh my gosh
that thing i did that thing i invested
my time into
that book i made that cost so much money
and so much time and so much energy and
so much effort that i thought was a
total waste time
was in fact the greatest thing i've ever
done for my career
and i've constantly looked back at
projects like that and looked back and
looked back and
just now i would say in the last three
to
four years i'm starting to understand
the importance of
investing into these long-term projects
these long-term goals or
i like to call them kind of personal
projects where it's not commercially
funded
and realize there's this great benefit
there and all i'm saying is i guess
there hasn't been this great moment
where it clicked i
i really slowly at a snail's pace kind
of
made this progress i did internships i i
worked under photographers i
learned bits and pieces along the way
and ultimately i was kind of given some
awesome opportunities to basically
go and and work on a book early in my
career
the california coast book yeah exactly
it was a road trip with a good friend of
mine from oregon new mexico
and it was so odd because i had
photographers who i really respected
kind of looking at me being like well
why are you doing a book you're 22 years
old i don't have a book and i'm like
i'm like to be honest i don't know you
know but looking back on that book
i all of a sudden realize this one and
again like it's never been in the moment
it's always like
six months later the book took three
years to make but i remember
one day i'm sitting there in san luis
obispo and i'm going to urban outfitters
for some reason and i'm like
my book is in urban outfitters my book
is in barnes and noble my book is in
this other
tiny mom and pop like travel shop and i
was like
wait a second i made this project that
has all the sudden got my work
in front of new audiences and i i
realized from like a business
perspective i was like
that's the best thing you could ever do
is like
work on projects that all of a sudden
get away from your core demographic
because i was i mean i was like surf 24
right i'm like have alerts on my phone
for when the next northwest swell is i'm
driving in my car
again i'm borrowing money from my
girlfriend to go up and down the coast
i'm
buying del taco for 35 cents a burrito
or whatever to like
get sustenance like that was my life was
like dirt bag surf photographer and all
of a sudden
i had this side project which felt at
the time like an incredible waste of
time and and i realized
wait a second this is kind of the key
this is what unlocks your door
to a greater audience and all of a
sudden from that book
and it took a while like licensing
opportunities came and then there were
people who wanted to hire me to shoot
other things and yada yada all these
opportunities unfolded and i just
i didn't fully dawn on me and i think
one of the big reasons
and this is something that stuck with me
forever was that when we were on that
trip we were on this road trip
and i've really tried to ingrain this in
younger
creatives or photographers that are
looking to be like what's the best thing
i can do for my career it's like
live and breathe with the camera never
in my life
did i have an opportunity where i woke
up every morning the first thing i
thought about was creating art and i
went to bed and the last thing i thought
about
was creating art did i shoot that photo
of the moon did i shoot that photo of
the
the trip we're on this 50-day road trip
from oregon to mexico
me and a friend in his 1976 volkswagen
bus
and our goal was to document every
coastal county and
i wanted to do that in the vein
of something that would be timeless
and i realized that everything i had
been working towards was to
sell magazines was to sell
advertisements for
a magazine and all of a sudden you have
a project where you're like wait you're
not selling to any advertisers you're
selling to an audience to readers
this could be a 65 year old couple that
kayak down the coast or
honeymoon or whatever you want it to be
relatable on so many levels so we
we really implemented the sense of
timeless we stripped all the logos off
of it
we we tried to shoot you know sunrise
and sunset to really get those strong
silhouettes and
that body of work to me became so
important because it set the standard
for what i wanted
everything else to look like and it's
still in print today
because the book is still relevant right
published when you were 21.
yeah 20 right two i think i think it was
actually like it we we started the
project in 2008 i think it
or six doesn't yeah and then it
published in 2009
ish something like that it was kind of
like right within that period right yeah
yeah and as i recall you were doing surf
gigs and starting to make a name for
yourself
and getting paychecks and you got a
decent paycheck for some gig and it was
like five grand
but you had you know your your tires
were wearing thin and yeah like metal on
the tires
bills that were unpaid and the rational
thing to do
would have been to like clean house at
that point right
buy it buy equipment buy something from
my car or whatever
instead you invest in your like the
lesson is like
trust your instincts yeah invest in
yourself and yeah
don't sacrifice like that short-term
gain
like oh i can get another paycheck like
this right have a longer view
vision for what you you want your life
to be like
and understand that these are all bricks
like in building this you know
infrastructure of who you want to be as
an artist in the world
completely spot on where
that's why there's never been a single
moment where you're like
oh my gosh when did you know you made it
i'm like well i didn't because every
time i got money
i would foolishly and reinvest in myself
and i don't mean that in the sense of
like
i needed the best equipment or i needed
the best car i need it was always like
what's the project or what's the trip
that i could create a great body of work
from that i could maybe like
sell for the next like five to six
months or whatever it is
and so it was always that reinvestment
reinvestment and even now like that's
how my wife and i work like and i always
bring her into the conversation because
she's been with me since the beginning
and it's kind of a
crazy thing to realize that i actually
i put so much um i put so much of that
i think success into my career into
having
somebody willing to support you because
i kind of had left that you know
right the home the nest with my mom and
it was me my mom always then
my stepdad came in and i could kind of
like detach and then um
finding the strong partner who is like
willing to say yeah that's the right
thing to do
and willing to kind of put a lot on hold
while i went on this 50-day road trip
well i went on this trip here well
you know so that's been a constant theme
in my life as strong
women who have supported me and i don't
think i would be anywhere without them i
will
back you up on that 100 yeah um you know
but art art doesn't exist without
commerce
yeah and sadly as you're recounting this
like i'm thinking about the conversation
that you have with chase jarvis which i
loved
because you guys are simpatico in terms
of things that you've done with your
life
um there's something that has to be very
intoxicating about
seeing your images on the cover of a
magazine that you used to read when you
were working in that shop
right and and the impulse is like well
more of that
yeah let's get the helicopter you know
get all the craziness
and chase there's a whole thing with
that right where
your ego is being sated and you're
getting paid very well and it's a very
comfortable living and it's a cool it's
a cool
life like you could exist in that space
for you know the rest of your career and
this is such an important topic
um and i want to kind of like side track
it a little bit here but his
his story about you know he's dreamt of
you know being at this level and i'm
sorry if i butcher it but
um but he's dreamt of being at this
level and he's there and it's like he's
got like four helicopters on standby and
he's doing this snow shoot it's for this
big
fortune 500 brand and and he almost just
feels detached from it like there's
there's no
there's no passion here and i i've been
in that exact situation i mean this is a
way fast forward later in my career but
it's taught me something really
significant that again
that constant idea that like it's a
crusade against the mundane and just
because my mundane might be different or
more exciting looking than yours
that's not what's important i've
realized that sometimes the most fearful
internal growth that i can do just be
being a good dad
and that's really where i've had to like
pour time and energy into these places
that scare me
or these places that i didn't feel good
at because you know when you're good
at managing a 60-person crew in a
multi-million dollar shoot and trying to
orchestrate all these people and you're
in charge it's terrifying
to go into that room and try to rock a
baby to sleep or something
but what i want to do you know who i am
yeah exactly child
you know yeah silence um the crazy thing
i've i've come
to understand about this process of kind
of
being on those big um big shoots where
like oh man your ego is just like
inflates right and you see your work on
the
on the you know the screensaver of some
high-end computer or you see your work
on a billboard driving down to la or
whatever it is is that
it's in those moments and i've promised
myself always
that the time to consider
that personal project that meaningful
story that new book
about that children's book or that book
on iceland's glacial rivers or that film
that you're doing about a friend and
parented that's the time when i want to
learn to say okay i know life is going
great and i could
milk this for all it's worth i could
milk this this
moment in my career where i'm kind of
elevating but if i don't stop and i
don't consider
what i could do to for the long-term
health
of not only me but of my career to do
something
meaningful and what i meet and i and i
and i want to make sure people
understand when i say meaningful
it's meaningful to put food on the table
it's meaningful to be a good provider
that's why collecting stamps and a
passport and a paycheck is a totally
fine thing but
there's a element of feeding your soul
that's so important and for
me there are these side projects that
have fed my soul
and it's in those moments of great
success that you have to learn to stop
and maybe even take a step back and be
like what am i doing
to sustain my own health and that's kind
of where
as a career as a photographer as a
creative as a husband
and that's really how and i've been able
to i think sustain
this business is because i've taken
mental stock and i've stopped
and i've tried to invest in these other
projects that aren't money-making
ventures they're just purely there
to keep me grounded it takes a lot of
self-awareness
though to engage with that process like
you've clearly done a lot of work on
yourself
because um you know a lot of people
wouldn't have the capacity to
pause like that so like what how did you
arrive at that
level of maturity yeah you're still a
young dude i'm not mature
i'm not mature
to be honest um there have been things
that have that have occurred in my life
that have happened in my life that have
forced me
to take mental stock there are things in
my life and issues and
things that have kind of halted me in my
steps and
and then i think certain things where
you see an opportunity
and it's so easy to be like i don't have
time for that i don't have time i don't
have time to do that yoga teacher
training i don't care about that stuff
and then my wife's like no this would
probably be good for you and i do it and
i'm like
oh my gosh like this just changed my
whole life this just changed everything
and
um that was one thing that was really
helpful like learning how to meditate
like
learning how to breathe correctly
learning how to slow down and
not because i ever had intentions of
teaching yoga but i wanted to have a
deeper understanding of that part of my
life and like
that was a forced slowdown and then
there were a bunch of other
things in my life that have kind of
whether whether i accept it or not
forced me to do that and now i look
forward to them i look forward to that
that thing
that's going to slow me down because in
doing that
i'm just looking to get back to the
magazine store i'm just looking for that
little bit of boredom that can spur that
creativity that can then get me back and
that sometimes comes with spending time
with my kids because their thoughts are
so simple and the things they love are
so
are so simple that i can get back to
that place um
sometimes it's it's on the hinges or the
heels of a personal project where
and that's what you find is that another
good thing comes from that and another
connection and another connection and so
there's sort of these two worlds you end
up operating and one is this
you know ultra high performing provider
that's trying to make a living
and then you have this other side that's
this you know you're trying to feed your
soul and be creative and put out
something meaningful and if it makes you
money great but if it doesn't you don't
even care because you're willing to be
the starving artist
and i think learning to realize that
they're you need to feed both these
yeah yeah yeah it's that tension that
that that basically
creates the path and i'm probably
projecting but i would imagine that
all the time spent you know in the
majesty
of these very imposing uh inhospitable
environments
gives you infuses you with a sense of
humility
and you know a perception of
your life and your relationship with
time that
right sizes you you know it's like
life's short man
like is it who really cares like when
you're in the
water and you're seeing these mountains
and these glaciers and things like that
like
just do what you love do what speaks to
you right this is
a funny concept too because um
again that mundane that chasing that
mundane thing you know like you you get
at some point you get
um sort of becomes common nature
you're seeing the beauty of the world
you're traveling all over the world i've
been to places and had experiences that
i literally could not describe in words
so how do i learn to i guess
synthesize it now um that's kind of
where
learning to tell stories in a different
way has come about that's why i'm riding
my bike that's why i got into climbing
that's why
i got into yoga because i was feeling so
much emotion
and i was feeling so much you know enter
i'm not a big energy person but
like i use the word sometimes so um i
think you are more than you
my wife is big i'm just like i'm like
it's the enter you know it's like but
i'm feeling this thing like i just
cannot compute and i'm like how else can
i synthesize this the camera's not doing
it
so is it cinematography is it spoken
word
is it me being willing to get up on a
stage and talk to people and share that
experience
totally stripped down from all my tools
that make me feel
successful or talented like you take the
camera away you take this it's just
a microphone right here you know in
front of you you're trying to to share
an experience
intimately with somebody and that is
kind of why i
have felt um the need to explore
different modalities of these places
it's why i went to iceland and wanted to
ride my bike around
last year in an ultra endurance race i
did this
ride called the wow cyclothon and this
was kind of the predecessor to this
current
ride i did through the interior i wanted
to do that because i wanted to know what
it felt this just sounds crazy i feel
like i sound like a full addict which is
fine
but i wanted to know what it felt like
to to
be there and when the wind picks up and
the rain picks up and the wind is
sideways and it's just blowing snow or
whatever it is
that i can't hide in a car that i can't
hide in a tent that i can't go to my
airbnb
and when you've been to a place that's
given you so much and you're willing to
subject yourself to
the worst it has to offer
i think there's something special
there's a connection there and i truly
feel that about the places i love like
i aim to experience that in yosemite or
in
big sur or in these places i love like i
want to whittle myself down
and strip the ego away and just be like
what's there
you know and that's kind of why i like
to do that
yeah yeah well that's the juice man yeah
i want to plant a flag there for a
second
divert for a moment and and address the
fact that i think
people get um get confused because
they'll they'll dial you up on instagram
and they see your
super groovy you know well-appointed
surf shack studio yeah and this like
amazing home and you've got
animals yeah alpacas and it paints this
picture of this idyllic
life you ride your bike to work and it
all looks super dope
yeah and and you know i'll you know when
i see that i'm like oh that would be
amazing
yeah like i uh if i just bank enough
cash like maybe i could
set myself up like that but in truth it
all
emanates from that instinct to go deep
within yourself to put yourself in those
places where you're confronted in the
most profound way with
with who you are yeah and it's a weird
scenario
to have this sort of um
i guess you could say a wire crossed
where you're like when things get too
good you have to remind yourself
of how hard life can be i don't know why
and i know there's
i mean that's a whole another talk on
their episode but i i
feel the need to remind myself of what
struggle
is not to say that i haven't experienced
it
because that gets me back to the core of
who i am and i i
and to i guess just to sidetrack a
little bit you know i have sometimes
people reaching out to me being like
again with that question like when was
that turning point when was that and i'm
like
there was never one because i never
wanted one i could have gone down roads
in photography i had opportunities to
move to la or san francisco take a job
photo editing and make good money
and like have a secure job but i didn't
want the security i wanted to always be
willing to sacrifice and
if you stay hungry it's always there and
so i think that
i look back at those early years like
again
my wife always laughs when i say this
but living like a poverty level you know
just
like kind of scraping by with pennies
under your mat and being like
i thrive in that place i love that place
because it reminds me of what i was
capable of
and i think in some ways i aim to
replicate that
in certain places because i never want
to get too comfortable
mm-hmm yeah in other words when you
think back on your career
it's not landing that first magazine
cover it's remembering sleeping in your
car and
yeah and it's yes yeah you actually that
was cool like you were having a good
time
right because you were on your path and
it sucked in the moment yeah
but hindsight is 20 20 perspective is
everything and i'm like you know what
had i not driven down the night before
and slept in my car or this and that or
again like random experiences throughout
the world like gotten thrown in a
jail cell in russia i would have never
gained that don't think we're not going
to talk about that yeah i mean
yeah i yeah i'm not throwing it out
there for dramatic effect but like those
were
life-changing experiences that i i look
back on as
great opportunities and you could look
at it be like oh it's pure stupidity it
was
but if you take that step back again
that was one of those halting moments
jarring moments where i'm like
i've got 24 hours in this jail cell to
think about every stupid decision i've
made in my life and why i've gotten here
and that
is one of those times where you're like
i'm gonna i'm gonna digest this and it
and i'm grateful for the moments i've
been forced to do that yeah
i was gonna go back and talk about the
the cycling race but
while we're on the subject of being
jailed in russia we might as well tell
this story now yeah
it's a funny one and it's one i've tried
to adapt into kind of like a good
um it's a presentation piece that i've
spoken at because
because there was a good lesson to be
learned it took me many years
to fully understand it right but the the
point being is that i was
in a time in my life where i just kind
of embarked on this journey of exploring
cold places
of these cold environments of you know
iceland and norway and yada yada
and i knew what i wanted to do in my
career as a surf photographer and as a
photographer in general
and so my sights were totally set maybe
even
narrowly set on where in the world
hasn't been explored where in the world
hasn't been served wherein
where could i you know be the first to
break open to so there was ego there and
um and with ego becomes complacency and
with complacency
comes i think a lot of
i think trying to jump over maybe some
some
barriers or guardrails of safety that
that really force people to to
acknowledge before they go into this
country and
one of those ones was just i i you know
i applied for all the visas to get there
i wanted to go to vladivostok which is
like the far end
uh the far east of russia it's a very
untouristed place at the time
and we line up all our ducks and we get
there and everything's great and we're
about to go through customs and i
remember vividly and i'm gonna try to
make the long story short here but
remember vividly looking every single
person
that i orchestrated their travel plans
to get there they one by one go through
customs boom boom boom
and i'm the very last one i'm just so
excited bright-eyed and i remember
looking at this customs lady and she
looks at me and i look at her and i'm
doing my best to do the non-verbal
exchange of like everything's good and
we're great this is going to be awesome
and it was just like immediately she's
like pointing to my
entry date on my visa and she's like
basically
saying no um and that's your date wrong
that escalated
into yeah a six hour interrogation of
why i was there
why my date was wrong and i'm like i
applied for all these visas at the same
time like there's no way i got my date
wrong i looked back my date wasn't wrong
it was a
it was a mistake on behalf of the people
that that had
made my visa in san francisco but the
reality was i was so blindsided so
excited about what i was
doing and my goal and this and that i
didn't even look at that
so i got there and basically the flight
left that went back to korea
and they were like i had a kind of a
fixer there olga and she
she negotiated with them and did my best
and
it was so sad because i could see her
face she's talking talking talking and
she looks at me and she's like
you know just looking terrible and i'm
like i don't know what to do i'm like
sweating bullets
and then she's like they're gonna detain
you for 24 hours maybe longer until the
next flight and then you're going to be
deported and i'm like
okay so when am i getting out and she's
like no you don't understand and i kind
of went to the state of shock
i'm walking with all my gear two armed
guards you know past all my friends like
the journalists the surfers all these
guys are staring at me and i'm i'm like
tell my wife i'm fine um luckily i had a
chance to keep my cell phone
but uh i get there and i'm i'm uh
all of a sudden i'm in this kind of like
this hotel across the street from the
airport that was more of like a um
uh you know municipal building and i'm
walking up to like the third floor and
there's all these rooms
with no handles and just locks and they
put me in this room and it's just bars
on the windows
caught on the floor water spilling out
of a
you know some sort of a toilet that's in
the ground and no door on the back side
and
and that was it and uh i remember
vividly in that moment calling my wife
and
and and just explaining to her because
married at the time it's pretty young
um like hey this happened be calm
everything's good yada yada i think the
second call i made was to at t to be
like i'm in a jail cell in russia i'm
gonna have a lot of phone bills can you
please just waive
the ten thousand dollar fee i don't know
why i went there but i was like this is
gonna happen
because i'm gonna be calling the u.s
embassy so my wife's on the phone
calling the embassy yada yada all these
things
all of a sudden she calls me back and
she's like okay
if they don't feed you you can probably
get out because that would be cruel and
unusual punishment they have to feed you
this is what the embassy said yadda
yadda um you know and
i'm like kind of thinking through these
scenarios here
all of a sudden six hours later uh a
guard knocks on my door
um and uh i'm just going to be totally
honest here his name was igor
he had one eye there was a small moment
where i thought this was a joke
right and right out of a bond right out
of a bond movie and i've been watching a
lot of 24 at the moment and i was
thinking like is there a way to break
out of here what am i going to do
um he he grabs me and
not grabs him but takes me down to this
kitchen
um very very bottom it's like just
stainless steel kitchen everything
looked like it had been you know used to
feed
large groups of military troops and
right in front of me there's
there's three cups there's like cucumber
a cup of mayonnaise
and then like some soup and i'm just
like i didn't want to offend the guy
at all so i'm like i'm just gonna eat
everything he offers me so i can get
through this experience
so they fed me and um there's one part
to this story that's actually like
i look back and i just can't help but
laugh so much but
coming from a small town and having kind
of a big family within that small town
you know you have these friends and
these people it's always like oh yeah so
and so has been to russia you should
talk to him
her chris about about her experience and
and things that you could learn and so
um i go to this family friend who had
spent time in russia you know before my
trip i'm like you know 21 years old
at the time and i'm trying to get a
little bit of like insight what to say
mannerisms just like trying to do my due
diligence this was the very
littlest bit of of research i kind of
did and she was like oh yeah okay so
here's three things you say thank you
you say this and if you need to go to
the bathroom you say this
and so when igor came to my room
i he opened the door
and i'm kind of doing that non-verbal
communication thing just trying to be
nice looking him in the eye
and uh and and then i'm i kind of point
to the bathroom and i'm like
i need to go to the bathroom like the
bathroom wasn't working right it was
like seeping into the floor
like all over everywhere and um
but i told him and i'm going to butcher
this because i don't actually remember
the term but i think it was
the the verbiage is cochuklismu and
he looked at me in a way that no man has
ever looked at me before
and uh it was in that moment that i
realized
what i had just told him was
was millions of miles away from can i go
to the bathroom
and i quickly turned the subject to like
oh okay let's go eat food wonderful i
will go with you like
as submissive as i could be you know it
wasn't until
weeks later and the funniest thing is
that when that
lady found out that i was in a jail cell
she was like calling my mom and calling
brie
and what's going on with chris you had
to get like freaking out we couldn't
really tell why
what i had told him was i need to edit
him a please right
and so it was just ultimately you were
punked
just not in the way that you thought
and i deserved it because i was
that
dumb kid who didn't look at my my entry
to my visa but like that moment would
just
always was seared into my memory and
and i remember coming home and i think
the long story short here is that
this process of wanting to become a
better person you you hope
it finds you through traveling but the
reality is it never does it's never
you know it's never climbing everest
that makes you a better person you're
the same person you started as you
ended and if that means you're a jerk so
be it right
that process starts before you leave
your front door and that was a really
hard way to learn that lessons it starts
by researching
um the place you're going to
understanding their customs
understanding their people understanding
that like this isn't a well touristed
place at all they
saw our cameras they saw my cameras and
regardless of if i had a good entry date
or not
i was going to be interrogated anyway
it's a military port right
it's the largest military port outside
of kamchatka and it was like
nobody was traveling there we didn't see
a single other american
and so just to go there with that amount
of ignorance just
really made me realize like that was an
experience i'm grateful to have it was
terrifying yeah i cried i've never had
my right stripped from me like that to
be in another country
where you don't speak the language you
don't know what's happening and you're
literally being deported back to korea
and you're on an assignment and
everything's kind of hinging upon you
making this trip successful like beyond
all that
i'm a you know young married man who's
trying to like make every trip valuable
because this is how i make a living and
so to come back
to my editor and my wife and everybody
be like yeah i just
had to rebook a flight to come to
vladivostok days later and i had to deal
with all this it's like
everything was just piling on me and
that stress and that cell was
palpable yeah it's a it's another like
lesson in humility
right like i had a a version of that i
got
asked to give a talk in karachi pakistan
early in this kind of phase of my my
career and i just thought this is the
coolest thing ever like no one's ever
going to ask me
if i want to go to pakistan again and i
just went like it's going to be
incredible
and i didn't ground myself enough
or educate myself about what i was
getting into
and it wasn't until i was on the flight
from dubai to karachi
and i'm sitting on this airplane and
looking around realizing i'm the only
westerner and when i got off the plane
uh you know being greeted by two guards
with you know
machine guns and having a very strange
experience going through customs
that i had this profound sense of just
how far away from home i was and just
how little i knew about what i was
getting myself into
and did that hopefully translate into
i'm guessing a great
learning opportunity for future of
course yeah and just an appreciation
you know for not just you know what i
have
but for uh you know the diversity of
experiences to be had by virtue of
traveling
and i think if if and when we can share
those things learned with others it
starts to
break apart the process and realize okay
this was valuable there was something to
be gained there was something to be
learned
others can hopefully not endure this
scary experience i had because of this
and i think that's where i found a lot
of the value
as well coming back to that storytelling
element you know right right right
all right well back to the uh the
cycling race yeah so you
you characterize this uh in a very
humble way
so let's be clear for people that are
watching or listening
this was a 850-mile
cycling excursion around the
circumference of iceland yeah
a famous ring road yeah yeah and i i
know i'm familiar with this race my
cousin did it as part of a relay
before you did and i kind of followed
him online as he did that cool
where's he from he lives uh up
in reno cool absolutely yeah i know a
lot of westerners come over and
um and do the it's like really really
beautiful and the relay team would be
the way to do it right exactly i mean he
was doing it for fun with his buddies
and there was no aspirations of
being competitive um i didn't even know
that there was a solo category
yeah and by all appearances not very
many people
opt for that no no so not only did you
do this
you actually like set the course record
yeah and
you're not coming from uh bike racing i
know you're an avid cyclist and have
been for a long time but
it's not like you were out there killing
races for years leading up to this
no so it's a funny thing because my
relationship with
endurance sports is a is an odd odd one
because i've chased
professional athletes around the world
for the majority of my career
and oftentimes you're on the sidelines
or you're you're
it's a hard thing to really explain
because like it's like if you ever want
to like learn what it's like to
to kill your joy of surfing become a
surf photographer all the very best days
where you're in the best waves in the
planet watching
you're not surfing right so your your
experience of surfing is limited to the
very worst days so
that's where i'm like i need to find new
hobbies um climbing became one of those
hobbies yoga became one of those hobbies
cycling became one of those hobbies and
to be honest i bought a bike
because i lived super close to my office
and i didn't want to
i just couldn't justify driving so i was
like i'm going to go to craigslist i
bought a bike for 400 bucks
loved the bike some old bianchi um
that bike became a tool for the weekends
to go explore i
love the idea of going down roads i've
been a lot of times in my community
and all of a sudden you're seeing it and
it's slower and it's more visceral and
and when my first son rolled around
jeremiah i realized that these three
four-hour rides and the weekends aren't
going to fly
so i kind of stopped and i really only
picked back up cycling maybe
two and a half years ago um yeah right
two and a half years ago basically
um because my kids are old enough and i
felt like i could take that time and
um i got a new bike and and like like
many things you know you get new toys
all of a sudden you're like oh man my my
fuel for this is reignited i just
remember feeling on that first ride like
the freedom i was like this is so
rad i i miss this i love this it's like
having a great day
surfing you know and it was such a nice
thing because again it was all about
commuting to my office
but then those rides would get longer
right which is what like four miles
exactly and then it was like oh i'm
taking the long way oh i'm going up this
hill oh i'm gonna go take like two hours
and ride around so
it just became longer and longer and i
and i kind of dawned on me like
you know there's something to be said
for like you enjoy doing something
don't you enjoy doing it as long as you
possibly can you know and
with other sports there's limitations
you can't climb for
18 hours straight like you're taking
breaks right you can't surf for
more than like six seven hours you'll
turn into a prune or you need food or
whatever
running too you know like you're
stopping at aid stations you're doing
this and that you have to
whatever so the thing the beauty of
cycling is i'm like wait i can
have food and i can have water and i can
have everything i need and i can have a
route and i can have a great podcast and
i'm like
it became this state of meditation where
i could think about everything
and it was just relaxed enough to where
i could take in my surroundings like you
can look around and like
enjoy what's going on you're not staring
at the pavement you're not looking at
the pool
the bottom of the pool you know i just
found that that was the one
athletic pursuit where i was like this
is this is everything i could
i was able to synthesize everything very
much in a way that i really enjoyed
and lo and behold much to like my my
colleagues my wife or my business
partners what not dismay like i never
really told anybody that
in the back of my mind there was this
idea
after learning about the wow cyclothon
race that maybe
i could do it or maybe i'd want to do it
it felt like such a distant dream memory
but i remember being in iceland years
prior meeting a friend a filmmaker who
was like i've done this race it's
amazing you would love it
come here do a relay um
and so i kind of secretly made that
decision and it's really
funny because for me everything when
it's goal-based is so much easier when i
have that focus
it's so much easier so i kind of went
into this
but not really saying anything to
anybody that i'm going to like do these
training rides like why
chris why are you riding eight nine ten
hours on a weekend i'm like oh you know
just
super fun but i'm like so what happens
after you do a century
you know what happens at 150 miles what
happens at 200 miles
what happens at 250 miles what happens
at 300 and that
that constant curiosity
kept me going and it kept me enjoying
the process of learning and all of a
sudden it was like
every mile more every hour or more
you're just
you're pushing whatever boundary you had
and you're kind of breaking through that
i mean like this is amazing and so that
that process of training really taught
me so much and
um i it's funny because i've kind of in
some ways
thought about having this conversation
with you as somebody who truly
understands
what you have to give to the training
process
um because you've done it you know so
much throughout your life and so it's
it was interesting for me because i at a
certain point i realized the miles the
hours
the sort of the the work on the body
becomes is important but it starts to
you start to get robotic and that just
becomes kind of commonplace you're going
through the motions doing this and that
like
what i realized was that what i needed
to do
was start to train my mind because
what's gonna happen
when it's hour 24 and you've never
ridden through the night and you've
never ridden
straight through the darkness and you've
never ridden with a tiny beam of light
in front of your face
where you're you've stayed up for 48
hours and you're still writing what's
going to that going to feel like what's
it going to feel like when you've eaten
a big meal and you're riding and you
have indigestion you feel terrible
what's it going to feel like when you're
sick so through that winter
i started going on these but what my
wife and friends would call just these
these psychotic like you know rides were
like wait get up at two in the morning
yeah like
but yeah thanksgiving night wait chris
you're going riding at midnight did you
just eat like
tons of apple pie and whatever i'm like
yeah i'm going out so it was like you
know i'd have these selfies with me just
like
bloodshot eyes and everything because i
knew that if there was any chance on
god's green earth i was going to be able
to endure that i had to prepare for that
because i didn't want any question
of what would happen and so maybe in
some ways i went into this over train
but i couldn't mimic the
the weather in iceland so i just tried
to go out in any situation where there
was rain there was wind
straight into a headwind and i had some
really
amazing experiences on that training
ride and when i went
and i did that race in iceland i hate i
mean we can't even i don't even know if
we're allowed to use this word anymore
but it was
as much of a spirit quest as i've ever
felt in my life
oh i don't doubt it i mean as much as
you train you're like oh i might have
over trained i mean
no matter how much you train how could
you possibly prepare for an
800-mile ride doing a century is hard
a double century is a gigantic feat i've
never ridden my bike more than 200 miles
like i've dipped my toe on ultra
endurance and i have a sense of this but
i've never done anything like right
800 i mean that's the equivalent of
like riding from la to san francisco
like two and a half times right this is
like an insane
undertaking it was psychotic and um
there was a fire there
that was unrelenting like
i got on the bike and i didn't get off
the bike for 12
for 10 straight hours i didn't pee i
didn't do anything i made i don't know
how i made like some sort of agreement
with my bladder i'm like we're getting
through this because in the beginning of
the ride
i had a tailwind that was the most
beautiful thing i've ever witnessed
and i did 200 miles
in 10 hours and it was an unreal i've
never
felt anything like it i was like this is
this is a dream i'm like i'm going to
commit to this
and you round a corner and suddenly the
wind's in your face
yeah so the first 24 hours in fact um i
did like yeah
400 something miles in in just under 24
hours
and that was the north part of the
country but then i got to the south
and it was like okay i've given you this
opportunity to experience the joy and
the beauty and the pleasure now
let's endure what's really here and i
remember coming onto the south coast
through the fjords
um you know hour number like 36 or
whatever it is no sleep and just on this
kind of caffeine regiment and
fuel regiment and feeling excited and i
see this
huge like whipped cream kind of like
like ice cream cloud above
the vanilla glacier area which is this
big glacier really close to the ocean
it's where the big ice lake is
and it's it's infamous for its winds the
south coast is where the
the most catabatic and large-scale wind
events happen and i got down there
i'm blanking on the name of the clouds
but normally i would i would know but
it's like
you can look at them and you're like
that's high wind and that's descending
upon me and i
remember coming around the head of the
mountain and it was like
i could not i was everything in my power
not to lay the bike over like i was
riding a 45 degree angle
you know deep dish wheels and you're
just sitting there like every
part of me was gripping like the
craziest thing is like the intensity of
a wind
i would rather ride in rain thunder
lightning everything but high wind is so
traumatic
that it just there's nothing you can do
it's like right it's like in
every so that was brutal and i had like
six hours of that and then i had
seven hours of rain and uh i got to feel
the
full everything you signed up for
everything i signed up for and
how much did you sleep i didn't sleep at
all um i didn't sleep for 66 hours
it was 66 hours it was it was a 52 52
hour race
but i you know i was up a couple hours
before that and then right
i after the race i ate you know and
because if i was just like to pass out
i'd be detrimental so i
ate no sleep yeah no sleep i tried to
sleep at hour 24 stay
upright on the bike did you hallucinate
oh i hallucinated
a hundred percent i i um the two things
that i felt
i remember very vividly it was seeing a
unicorn
and then um and then well you're in
iceland you could have
seen me there were horses but i was like
that like it was like this white horse
on a pedestal of rock with all the other
horses below it and i was like
it was like amazing and and then fully
and then i got it my friend ellie who i
made the film about right
he had made me a little hot tub at his
parents house and i get in the hot tub
and i'm like ellie
there's a snake in here you gotta get
the snake out of here a button he's like
there's no
reptiles in iceland none and i'm like
okay it was it was pretty funny and then
i i passed out but the reality is i mean
you know this feeling like you i tried
to sleep at hour 24
my legs were just throbbing so much that
i couldn't sleep it wasn't even
it would have been better just to keep
going i think that and i
i wish i wouldn't have tried to sleep
because i could have got a faster time
but um the funniest thing is going into
the race the whole mindset for me was
like
what i told people is like i just want
to finish it it'll be a great goal to
finish it but in my back of my mind i'm
like
what if you could win what if you could
set a new course record and knowing what
that was going to require of me
physically
was um maybe in some ways
uh like a little psychotic but yeah
but i it was a such a beautiful
experience like i wouldn't take
and i wouldn't take anything away from
that you know well
the whole thing was shared in real time
on instagram
stories and i remember following it just
being like wrapped including all your
training
leading up to it yeah that was really
cool to watch was there any other
solo category writer that year there
were two there was one named erica
who is um he has won it three times he
had the current speed record
awesome icelandic guy just a beautiful
soul
he made it about a eighth of the way
and then i think he was having knee
issues so he gave up but um
our dnf'd sorry but um it was funny
because in the beginning i've got
you know it's a fully sagged race you
have to be i i personally wish it was
more of a self-supported scenario but
um i had never dealt with sag before so
i didn't know how to do all this bottle
handoff and all these things that's
another
context in which they say don't work
with your friends yeah
fully and i but i was grateful enough to
work with some people that i knew
decently well and they put up with me
amazing
but i was at the beginning i'm like hey
guys i'm just gonna load up as much food
and as much water as i can so i like
went off the line really heavy because
i'm like because i just
don't want to deal with the hand off and
the calling you on my phone or having a
walkie
um and so that was kind of what i did
that was sort of the way i
went about it was i carried like 60
ounces of water and
i carried like 6 000 calories on board
and just tried to not stop that was my
that was my method i'm
not going to go fast i'm just not going
to stop yeah but anyway at a certain
point we're 24 hours in i'm like guys
i'm like i know i'm doing decently where
is
where are the other soloists there was
another gal from alaska who was a
soloist
and they're like oh man they're not that
far from you like blah blah and
they didn't tell me until like hour 40
that he had dnfed a while back and i was
it was so funny i'm grateful i'm so
grateful they didn't because that's like
true friendship they're like
they're like they know there's a fire
fire yeah um
and uh yeah it was it was a brutal year
for weather and everything but it was it
was a wild experience i remember in the
beginning just being so excited
i'm like you have to keep when you're
doing those solo rides you have to keep
a distance from the person in front of
you or the person behind you right so
you're
you're forcing yourself to keep a speed
and they're like chris don't pass him
because he was kind of setting the pace
and
i kept thinking like okay well this
person's done this a million times like
they know iceland they're from here like
this is the person i should be following
to set the pace and when the time is
right if i can
overtake do it you know maybe like
tomorrow
but it was like mile 11 and i'm like
guys
i'm so excited i can't do this like i
cannot go at this pace we were going
like
whatever and i felt the tailwind and i
was like later and i just
bolted and i never saw him again if i
was in your crew van i would have told
you to chill out
that's like beginner's enthusiasm that
you just you can't repay that debt
100 and i and my excitement got me into
a couple other scenarios i remember
going around a roundabout and it was
raining and i like flew off the
roundabout
because i was it was all wet and i like
went into the ditch and just rode
through it like they're like wow what is
this guy
doing he's what was the former record um
i think it was 56 hours
so you broke the record by four hours
yeah and a part of me
legit part of me is sad because i knew i
there's moments from like i should have
i could i didn't have to make up time
there knowing the course
would have been a huge advantage but i
was blessed with incredible weather
and i knew that but that's the beauty of
a circle right you're always going to
get
a tailwind somewhere but again there's
been years where it's
frosted and snowing and years they've
had to call it off years they've had to
change the route because of 90 mile an
hour winds
wow so yeah all the elements
yeah terrible yeah you wouldn't be able
to ride through that that's nuts
so when you finish that are you thinking
never again
or like what's the next thing when i
finish that race
my mom and my wife showed up in iceland
and i
purposefully planned it because i i kind
of told him like hey you're gonna be
there when i finish
like this would be the normal time i
finished 72 hours it's kind of the
average finishing time
i finished earlier and i was grateful i
did because like 20 hours yeah they
weren't there yet so they couldn't see
me in like this
really fragile state so i finished and
um
the beauty was like this was the first
international trip i was ever going to
be able to take my mom
on in her life and so i come off this
incredible high
of this experience and just all the
emotions flooding through my body and
everything you can imagine when you're
hallucinating and you're running on pure
adrenaline and
and then all of a sudden kind of wake up
from this like deep slumber and
have my mom my wife there and be able to
be like now i get to show you
you know the two most important people
in my life like the beauty of this place
i love
so much and that was like that was
the the congratulations that was the
success that was the
podium like that was the greatest thing
ever and so i i like
didn't sleep woke up i'm like i'm
driving you guys to all my favorite
spots
we did like a 24 hour push and saw
everything we could and uh
and then went back to the award ceremony
and it was just like that was the
coolest experience ever and
to be able to share that was like yeah
i can't think of a greater 72 hour
window of my life
wow that's awesome the landscapes are
just
insane there like i'm thinking of there
was one clip in the
in the film where um
ellie's like walking on the top of this
cliff and there's this like
um
it's all volcanic basically almost
everything there has been created by
volcanoes and glaciers and so you have
all this beautiful
uplift where kilometer basalt is created
and then like everything wears away and
it's left there and it's kind of like
hanging teeth almost like a some
medieval castle and
that's what's so weird is that when
you're there you're walking through this
landscape
it's one of the youngest on earth and
you feel it
like you feel that intimacy that
closeness with it and you're walking
through places that are
in some ways relatively unsafe because
the landscape is changing and things can
fall away
right this is like the earth percolating
up yeah
exactly rawest form yeah so in the wake
of that
cycling experience like how does that
change or inform
your world view or like how you think
about the creative process
you know what's so interesting was i i
as much as it was just amazing to do
and experience sharing it was so
valuable
and showing people that like i come from
relatively no experience i'm not
a gifted you know cyclist in any regard
i'm not
i mean if anything i've learned how to
take
a photograph and and make a film but to
be able to kind of understand and share
with people that
in order to truly know a place and
experience it you have to subject
yourself to it in some way you have to
be willing to and i think that
that experience of sharing the story
of the race of the training of all those
things and my commitment to
place my commitment to to experience i
mean i
i will sum all that up is like i didn't
ride a bike
to get exercise i didn't ride a bike to
stay up for 66 hours and
or to burn 35 000 calories i rode a bike
because i wanted to
know what it felt like to have to be so
insignificant in an
environment that i love and to feel so
small to remind myself of what that's
like
because that's what it felt like the
first time i was there and so
we look for opportunities to do that in
our life and i'm not saying the bar
needs to constantly be raised and
the risk needs to constantly be elevated
but i i do feel like there's moments in
your life when you realize like
the time is now like there's never going
to be another window
and i think what i what i hope people
kind of can
understand from that is like i turn
down work to do that i had read
in the process of training greg
mckeown's book
essentialism have you had a chance to
read it i have yeah
it's about it's really about deciding
what's essential in your life and he has
this amazing mantra that he talks about
where
you know learning to say no is really
learning to say yes to what you want and
um as somebody who has been a yes man
their whole life
for for good reason because i was again
uh raised by
a mom and my my dad who basically like
super blue collar and any work that came
was good and
and i still witnessed that that hard
work ethic today
like saying no to work was was not even
on my radar
so to realize that i've gotten this
place in my career where i have the
ability to
maybe say no to something in order to
give myself to something i really want
was a really beautiful experience and
that's where i just felt
like the real learning happened and
occurred right
yeah i mean i think that comes part and
parcel with success
you know the the drive
to advance your craft require saying yes
to so much
you know that's part of what it means to
build a career like just
doing stuff for free always being
available and all of that and then you
reach a certain inflection point
and you can't do that anymore that will
bury you right so you have to develop
these boundaries and learn how to say
no to things and and and yeah and
develop that sense of
clarity about what's most important and
that's the part nobody teaches you
nobody teaches you how to say no i mean
everything all the workshops
out there everything like how to say yes
how to you know but
and how to be more efficient but that's
been the hardest thing is like
realizing that statement like saying no
is saying yes to what you want and i
said yes
something i wanted and it it gave me a
beautiful gift and it gave me
a sense of um pride and a sense of that
and i think this is what it comes back
to is we're looking for validation in
everything we do that's the world that's
that's like growing up in 2020 is
is social media is just a sense of
validation and everything we do and so
i've always realized again when
sometimes things get too easy and or
receiving validation can sometimes feel
like a slot machine a little too easy
on social media for example you know you
can share something and have millions
people like it and it's that i have to
remind myself okay
real validation doesn't come from
an app doesn't come from people that
don't truly know you i think it comes
from making somebody
proud feeling love feeling that intimacy
feeling that connection to place feeling
that connection to story
and maybe in some ways riding your bike
850 miles around the country
feeling some sense of um a greater
purpose that you know
and i think that's what it was all about
that validation that like
you worked for this and you achieved
this that's something i feel like i'm
constantly searching for in my life in
different ways
well there's a fidelity to your value
system like i look at that bike race
as a close cousin to the decision to get
into a vw van and go up and down the
coast like these are
relate these are not unrelated um you
know inspirations
right it's a way of recapturing the
innocence of that experience by putting
yourself in
an environment that's unfamiliar to you
and the learning that comes and
you know to your point about social
media i mean you're a guy who
who you've got like i don't know four
million people on instagram who follow
you
which is insane right and that has to
induce some level of vertigo right like
how do i manage this and
how do i um you know shoulder the
responsibility
of communicating at such a mass level
and in trying to deconstruct like how
you got to this place where so many
people are interested
in in experiencing you know life through
your lens
there's a lot of really technically
talented
nature and adventure photographers out
there who are doing amazing things
so why is it that you have four million
and somebody else who's
you know perhaps equally technically
skilled has
you know a a middling size audience and
the only answer that i can come up with
is is really your superpower which is
this capacity for
bringing people along and and the story
the humanizing storytelling
aspect of it by you know capturing these
austere
environments and translating the meaning
of that
um through you know your emotional
landscape in a way that connects with
people that makes them feel like
you know as i said at the outset like i
feel connected to you because of your
ability to
storytell in that way and that means a
lot i i appreciate that and i would just
say that with that like i aim i i've
realized early on in my career
um that i really prided myself on trying
to document
experiences sports places locations that
that
felt approachable that felt accessible
and yeah occasionally i'll
shoot somebody you know high lining
through an eclipse or a moon or
something just off
you know crazy but for the most part
like i'm just a
you know five eight short dude with with
no athletic background who
gave the time and commitment to
something and did it and i
want people to realize that absolutely i
am not the most technically sound
photographer absolutely i'm not the most
creative
i'm just the person stupid enough to
commit themselves to something
enough to see it through and i think
that's always been my strength and
that's always been
my goal and i want others to understand
that if they come from an impoverished
situation or they come from an unlikely
situation
and if they're willing to work for it
they can get they can they can
be in this situation and i think that's
kind of been something i've prided
myself on is trying to tell stories that
feel approachable
trying to tell stories that feel real
and with this bike ride again it's like
that's a real
and or approachable story that people
can relate to and whether they want to
be in that situation or they just want
to
root along the sidelines like that's a
really awesome experience to share with
somebody the vulnerability
of of how we present ourselves online is
i think so important for
people to understand and relate to and
i've really tried to put emphasis on
what i
say as much as what i share visually
that being said you know we're in this
day and age where
uh it's so easy to just strip some
beautiful quote off the internet or tell
people that
the mountains are calling and they must
go and really that means
nothing like this is the place you make
your own quotes
the books the films the social media
what have you this is the place where
you tell people what it
felt like to be there because to be
honest you
only do people a disservice by
describing what they can see in the
photo you have eyes this is a
visual platform you have to engage with
it visually
i don't need to tell people that it's
cold and the person's surfing in cold
water and there's mountains and guess
what we're in norway
i need to tell you the visceral
experience of what it felt like to be
there because
that's all i can offer because as a
photographer as a storyteller
what did it feel like for the snow to
hit the back of my neck what did it feel
like to
feel the crunch of it under my feet
would it feel like to push the trigger
of the the camera what did it feel like
to you know to document this moment and
why
and so i think that in many ways those
are the questions i'm seeking and
whenever i'm doing any
like again whether it's taking a picture
whether it's making a film or speaking
or
riding a bike like i want to share those
things because that's i think what
people connect to
yeah i think that's such an important
point that there is
a thought process and a methodology and
a deconstruction of how to tell
a good story that you just kind of
walked us through
that is in contrast to you know the
words like
oh you know authenticity and
vulnerability like they've been
thrown around so much that they've been
drained of all their meaning
and you're seeing a lot of perf i've
said this before but like a lot of
you know performative authenticity
online
yeah which is the antithesis of
authenticity itself
and i think it's leaving people confused
about what authenticity
truly is because it's been co-opted by
you know kind of capitalistic forces oh
like if you're authentic then you can
like get an audience and so there's
always weirdness online right now
which is very different from stripping
you know these experiences down to their
true meaning and really like
searching inward for the words or the
lessons
or what it is that you want to
communicate about
the interior experience of these these
travels that you go on that
is truly connected when you know that
it's a privilege to go there when you
know
that it's a blessing to go there when
you know that you've been given and
dealt a hand that
that feels at times surreal i feel
indebted
to share that i felt indebted to come
back to my mom
and share this experience with her
because she never
went anywhere she never traveled outside
the us until she went with me
30 years later so i've always felt that
debt to share these experiences because
i know that yeah i worked for it and
yeah
it was hard yadda yadda but ultimately
it is a privilege and i feel grateful
to be able to to do this and i feel like
that's a huge part of the story is being
able to bring this to
the masses whether they can relate to it
or not
i'm not sure but i'm doing my darndest
to hope that they can i'm doing my
darnest to hope that
the people through my struggle or my
experience of
raising kids or heck raising alpacas or
whatever that is can understand that
like there's a realness there
and i just i think there's just yeah
again there's a
bit too much of the opposite kind of the
fake fake news that we get online right
it's challenging
one of the things that you talked about
with chase that i thought was
interesting was this importance of
of kind of having a mission statement or
a vision for your life like if you don't
have that
how are you anchoring your behavior and
your activities how do you know
how to move forward in the right way so
talk to me a little bit about
how you think about creativity and how
you kind of plot
your moves you know along this career
path yeah that's a that's a really good
question
and i'll just be the first one to say
this took me a long time to figure out
like
again that the beginning of that career
was all you know stamps in the passport
and collect a paycheck and then
again all of a sudden you're spending
enough time in these places and you're
like
there's something more here there's got
to be something more and
and searching for a path like
you can't see the the forest the trees
if you're just kind of like constantly
going oh well this seems like a good
idea well this seems like a good idea
so what roots you in a sense of
knowing when to say no to say yes like
where does that come from you have to
have a guiding force and
um that the book essentialism by greg
and killing was a reinforcement of this
but ultimately years prior i kind of
came to the conclusion like
what is my guiding light and and what is
my purpose and
ultimately it should be something you
can tell somebody an elevator so that
they understand and i've always used
this example
because it's easier to use somebody
else's example than my own but like
young photographers come to me sometimes
and they're asking for advice and the
first thing i tell them is i say well
who do you want to work for and they
tell me the names and i'm like okay
what do they stand for and they kind of
like what's their mission statement
and i'll use the example of national
geographic like you want to work for
national geographic
you know everybody in the room raises
their hand well what's their mission
statement they're like oh
like you know something something like
no it's it's to inspire people to care
about the planet now
everything they do their film digital
social all these properties
live underneath that one umbrella so the
sooner you understand that and you align
yourself with that the sooner that you
can potentially forge a relationship
with them and so i think for me i've
taken
my own advice and that advice to figure
out well i have this
singular focus and yes i do a lot of
different things
but as long as they all support the
overarching goal
and heck one of those things these
aren't just all altruistic
pursuits right one of those things can
be like you know i need to go shoot this
tech brands thing because that's going
to put food on the table and that's
going to provide a great education for
my kids
and that is something that's worthy of
my time but
i need all these things to feed this
greater goal because
for me there's been times in my life
where i've chosen to turn down work
because it didn't fit with my moral
standards or it didn't fit with my
values or i
i also didn't think that it was going to
in any way push my career in the right
path because we're only going to bring
back the work that we put out there
how important well i know it's important
like what is the role that
that that faith plays in all of this for
you yeah it's a it's an immense
it's an immense role it's a guiding
force it's a guiding light and i
ultimately feel like
so much of what i um
of what i am today is based upon my
decision to
in in any in many capacities basically
kind of have
a um a faith based basically
family and business and it's been a
challenge too because i i've
grew up um lds i i converted when i was
actually like eight or nine so i didn't
grow up in in that church but i um i
didn't serve a mission and that was like
a huge sense of guilt
on my shoulders for many years mainly
because
during that period of dissension from my
mom and from doing what
you know they thought was the right
thing i made a lot of stupid choices and
that
that really sat with me for a long time
and so i'm never going to be the person
to
tell somebody you know what what to vote
for what to pray for who to worship
that's not i
i've aimed and hoped that i can steer my
career in a way
and share my work in a way that it
glorifies what i value
which is family and which is god and and
which is nature and which is people
finding the answers to hard questions by
being outside
so in this yeah and in this now
political kind of environment we find
ourselves i can't think
of a more important role than trying to
make sure that
the outdoors are um open to everybody
you know because i've found so much
healing there
as a young kid and i've found so many
answers there and i just
the idea that someone can't find that
out there is it kills me
right yeah that was a big thing that
that mueller was sharing the other day
and an impetus behind his work with
shark preservation just this idea that
like these animals are disappearing and
he's got these young daughters and he
wants them to be able to experience them
the way that he does and this sense of
you know impending
degradation of the environment and as
somebody who's gone to all these amazing
places that are so far off the beaten
path
you know that has to instill in you this
um call to action to make sure that we
protect these places and also kind of
you know you you get out to the ends of
the earth and what you find out there is
it's a bit lonely
and you kind of have these experiences
and it sometimes feels a bit like a
burden to bring them back
like you know that sounds like the most
pretentious thing you could ever say but
the reality is like
it's hard to bring sometimes these
stories or these photos back and
and share just how significant or just
how
fragile it was or just i don't even know
how much plastic you saw on this beach
in the middle of absolutely nowhere
that's supposed to be the most pristine
environment on the planet
it can feel a bit burdensome to like
have that and and feel like you want to
do something but feel
um i feel kind of chained like
you just you don't have the ability and
so i think for me
using a platform to share what i've
experienced firsthand
it's been a big part of it and just
that's kind of i think in many ways why
yeah yeah i've wanted to what's the
craziest
place you've ever been to or the place
that kind of surprised you the most
um it's not going to be what you think
um the place that surprised me the most
that i've ever been
was a massive
trash dump in nicaragua called lachureka
which was at one point labeled as one of
the
seven like worst places on the planet
because it was a place
of child prostitution and families
living in these trash dumps and it was a
time in my life
where i was looking for answers kind of
before i started searching for cold
weather locations i was watching a lot
of
james notway's war photographer and
studying salgado and
trying to think that maybe i wanted to
be a photojournalist because i was
feeling
i was feeling very um unfulfilled being
this surf photographer right being on
these beaches
chasing the tasty waves and bikinis and
my ties people are sitting down and i'm
just like
in the middle sitting there this like
this mormon kid like okay cool this is a
really great experience of having so
much fun and
so like you know rip curl or ruka brings
you down there but then you're like i'm
gonna go to the trash eep
and check that out what ended up
happening was i i kind of started to
look for opportunities outside of these
trips i went down to nicaragua
to shoot a job for patagonia with some
of their athletes and i was on
i was on a retainer for patagonia for a
number of years shooting all their surf
team and
it's an amazing experience i learned so
much from jane siebert the
the um the photo editor there she was
kind of like a
second mom to me at a time and she
really this is a name hopefully you hear
a future in the future but like
jimmy chin renaud oster keith all these
amazing photographers corey richards she
gave a lot of them their start corey
richards like
their first published photo like was her
and she was in many ways like this kind
of
just another strong woman in my life and
i remember
it's kind of a backstory here we're
going with her to
this conference that she
she and patagonia sort of nominated me
for called look between it was a
it was a festival of emerging
photographer talent
it was in the south and it was right by
um
nick nichols um he's the famous nat geo
photographer that shot the photos of the
trees where he took like 3 000 images
and stitched them all together and
did all the jane goodall work with the
the gorillas and
and just i mean his work is iconic and
he put together with a lot of other
photographers this
this conference for emerging work and i
remember going there
i remember sharing a slideshow with all
these emerging photographers like
people who now all have these amazing
social media followings and have done
all this weight work
and just feeling so insignificant
because i'm there
sharing like oh yeah here's my book
project of the california surf trip and
we're going up and down the coast and
two white dudes in a van you and they're
like oh yeah here's like the aids
epidemic and we're you know and i'm just
like
i just was i remember leaving feeling
proud but also just internally and this
is just my own issue
yeah but you're also like a teenager
yeah fully you know but i remember
but like i think jane wanted me to go
she wanted me to see
what else was out there she saw some
talent and i was so grateful
for that opportunity she gave me to like
realize what was out there and the
stories being told and she kind of said
it without saying it like
you can you can do more and whatnot and
um
this is a really like discovery time in
my life anyway long story short i'm on
assignment for patagonia i go down to
nicaragua and afterwards
i was there with a handful of surfers
that had been pretty involved with a um
a really awesome group called love light
melody that would go in and spend time
with these kids and raise money to
create schools in there and i mean this
place was the most
atrocious environment i have ever seen
in my entire life
i've never witnessed that kind of
poverty i had never witnessed that kind
of sickness i'd never witnessed
what was happening in a place like this
being so sheltered and i remember going
there
and that was the experience that truly
i never felt more powerless like
talk about talk about a career path
where you just
go home at night and every day you just
like
want to cry like i can only imagine the
work of a lot of these photographers
these photojournalists they just must be
so hardened
because and that's just my perspective
yeah you have to be
otherwise you just would fall apart i
left
in shambles i left speechless i went
there hoping
that i could document this experience
then in some way share that
and i went home just realizing like i
can't do that
and it was so hard because i had these
sort of again delusions of grandeur i
did a couple trips i went to india and i
went
and i and i wanted to document kind of
what was happening
social justice issues in the world and
um luckily
thank goodness la chareca has been since
then cleaned up and relocated and a lot
of these
children were taken out of prostitution
and um
but to be there and to document it and
some of the images were used to kind of
promote promote what was going on
i just felt so powerless and that was
kind of in the moment that i was like
you know what i'm going to
set my sights on something you know
maybe i'm not going to be going to these
tropical beaches
i definitely know that i me as a person
i just couldn't that's not your lane
i just couldn't handle it yeah and so
you have all these images that you've
never shared from that experience i do
i've shared a couple
it's just hard to share them it's hard
to share kids and
you know photos of kids and literally
underwear who you're like
i don't know if that kid is alive like
that
is a challenging thing um i came back
from that trip
and again this is so funny because life
has such a weird way of forcing you into
like
like i i if i if i would have
just gone on the sort of day-to-day life
i probably would have just gone home
from that trip
put all those images down not thought
about them kind of
put that emotional duress away and then
gone another trip but i came home
and i had a massive uh
medically resistant staph infection
growing in my leg and i was forced into
bed for 30 days i had gotten it from
tahiti
the trip before because again i was just
globe trotting tahiti nicaragua
yada yada i came home and what i thought
was a spider bite
was actually medically resistant staff
um
and scary the abscess just started to
grow and i remember being in bed and
sitting there and i
and all of a sudden i'm like well now
i've got to deal with all this and so
we talked about this internalization
right like i think that in some ways
it's important to realize why is this
happening well this is happening because
maybe i need to deal with this and i
need to
understand and i think it was in that
moment
on that bed rest where i couldn't move
and you know red lines are crawling up
my leg to my heart that i was like okay
what do i want to do with my career
what do i want to do with my life how do
i wanna and i and i kind of came to that
conclusion that
you know sharing these off the beaten
path beautiful places the world where
you can really
you can really find that joy and there
is a sense of adventure in there it
can be scary that can be valuable i
don't need to
totally dismiss that as a career path
and i think that that's
ultimately what i ended up settling on
and that's really what set my sights on
i think
cold water exploration yeah that's so
amazing yeah
to to be in that place of of being
forced to slow down like
as somebody who's always chasing
adventure you know it's
you're constantly on the move and it
never gives you a moment to reflect on
why it is that you're doing what you're
doing or what it means or
am i even on the right path well there's
that famous quote like you know you're
so busy doing what you're doing do you
ever stop to ask if
this is the right thing to do and i was
kind of on that path
and um and that's a hard thing to
swallow it's a hard pill to swallow when
you're you're
fully aware and you become cognizant to
the
struggle and the strife that's happening
out there and this is right around the
time
my wife and i were talking about having
our first kid and this and that and i
just couldn't even bear the thought of
like
bringing children to the world knowing
there was so many suffering and
um i felt again like that was a real
um turning point for me of just
understanding where my voice
voice could best be used how i could
best be a tool
to help people so how do you think about
your role as as you know kind of a
mentor or somebody that young people
look to
for creative inspiration like what is
the message to the next generation of
creators out there yeah um you know that
there's so many to be honest because
there's always always one-liners where
i'm like you need to do
this but kind of to take a step back
when i was in the impetus of my career i
remember reaching out to so many people
so many photographers people i respected
people i trusted looking for an
internship an opportunity someone to
learn from a mentor
and just like so many doors slammed in
my face i became very good at that
and i told myself at one point i was
like if i ever get to a place of success
i want to make sure that i'm
different that i offer opportunities to
teach and and i think that that's been a
big part of my career now is like
again i kind of have my fingers you know
all you got those courses and you've got
the creative live
thing yeah and just like again podcasts
and sharing
being willing to share like there was a
moment and i mean
i'm sure it's like this with you know
even with athletics and sports too like
there is a moment where like the best
sort of photographer or athlete or
whoever was the person who's the most
removed the most cut off the most
protected
and yeah that was like you know early
90s and nowadays
because of social media and one of the
benefits is like
no the person who's the most available
the person who's the most real the
person who's the most accessible
that's the person that not only you
usually want to connect with want to
follow but also
commercially the brands want to engage
with the brands want endorsing a product
the brain you know
so there's value there on many levels
and i've just
realized like hey i just want to strip
away all the ego and be like this is
what i've done and this is how i've done
it and this was what worked for me
you don't need to do it this way and i
think that one of the key things i
realized early on in terms of that piece
of advice
is that you don't need to be good at
everything and that
idea that you need to come to the table
with a portfolio
as a creative specifically as a
photographer
that's like you know for example i shoot
weddings and i shoot portraits and i can
shoot action sports and
it's like no that's that's not real like
you're hired by somebody because you're
the best at what you do and oftentimes
the more of a specialist you are the
better and i think that
you know to use my my good friend paul
nickland as an example like he's the
best at shooting under antarctic ice
he can shoot beautiful afghan
portraiture but it's not the assignments
he's given
and so he understands that and i think
when you pick that lane and you
understand like this is what i love
the work starts to come pretty easy and
it doesn't mean you don't work on other
things you don't
process other things you don't you don't
build that repertoire along the way but
it's important to understand that like
i want to be known or i've wanted when
i've worked magazines be known for like
this skill chris can do that and that
that's what gave me a really successful
career um yeah
this idea that in the giving is where
you get the most back right and i talked
about that with
with chase like he was one of the first
people in your field
to start sharing the you know the
secrets of photography that was always
like protected in the black box and
never tell anybody how you do what you
do
because that's our bread and butter and
if you do that you're letting the cat
out of the bag and i know
a lot of photographers who have a very
strange or antagonistic relationship
with instagram it's like oh now
everyone's a photographer you know what
i mean
there's a cynicism around that but when
i look at you i look at somebody who
not only embraced it but used it as a
tool a teaching tool a tool
for inspiration and also let's not
forget like this incredible
you know branding tool to create this
sensibility about who you are and what
you stand for that becomes
you know a commercial asset for you in
the long run
and i want to kind of like set the
record straight too for people who have
a confusion like
social media has in so many ways
benefited my career because it's allowed
me
to give my voice to things but that
is the way it operates i i was
again for about eight years prior to
ever using facebook my my wife is the
one who told me to use facebook
my wife is when he told me to use
instagram i was like i'm never going on
there
the reality is that back in the day it's
so funny to say that
being 34 driver but back in the day if
you were to share a photo on a trip
before your editor got it they would
you'd be fired like i remember being on
these trips and
and and sharing these photographs and
and you know
having this contention with the magazine
the reality is
i would go on these assignments i would
go to russia for example i would have
this life-changing experience i'd be in
a jail cell whatever it is
and there'd be thousands of images in
the story that was told was the one from
the journalist's perspective and all of
a sudden there's all these images left
over
and i'm like what about all these
stories what about all these photographs
and
i turned to i think it was a wordpress
or blogspot to to write a blog i would
i wrote about the time i flooded 30 000
with a camera gear in chile and people
would
connect with me and i would talk to them
about it you know as a cautionary tale
of this and that and it was a
it was a side story to the story that
came out in surf line right
and then i went to facebook and i
started doing the same thing and then
when instagram came along
i realized like this is just another
tool to share my side of the story and
that's what it always has been
yeah there are perspectives out there
that you'll read in
the magazine or in see in the film or
whatever but to have all these images
that for me are again just big fish on
the wall they're tall tales right sort
of thing
that i can share with an international
audience that's super powerful and
that's
i try to remind myself of it when
opportunities come when it's like you
could sell this and you could do this
and
that like this is the reason i use this
tool
and i feel completely full well this is
why i found success in that platform is
because
it's been that and i've tried to keep it
that way yeah it gives you the freedom
to tell
like you said your version of the story
i didn't even think of it in that
context but when you're on a gig
you're there to serve the journalist
story not your own story or the creative
director
or the brand you know and that's one
side it's usually a good side of the
story because you're helping with
creative but
there are there are things that happen
like again russia yeah we got waves
we surfed it was a cool experience we're
the first to do so yada yada yada but
the life-changing story for me the one
that's going to be significant to people
and the one people are going to remember
is that 24 hours i spent in that jail
cell crying to my wife on the phone
trying to figure out
that you know so those are the things
that i aim to write down and what i've
realized is that
social media is one place to do that
there are books there
are films there are places to tell that
story and as a storyteller the way i
filter the world
now as i look at these platforms that
are available to me that i've created
and i wonder there's a story to tell
what is the best way to tell it
like is it through social media is it
just in a couple posts or in a carousel
is it through a film that i'm gonna
invest in um
or i'm gonna seek a partner for is it in
a book again
iceland's glacial rivers i've shared
photos of iceland's glacial rivers for
six seven years but i couldn't put ten
thousand words of
important research documentation of
what's gone on
on social media that's why a book is
needed
and i think that being true to that
sense of storytelling you need to look
at
all those opportunities are available to
you and if not explore them
or invest in them because that's what
they've always been to
so what's next for you you got the film
coming out but you also
you're working on this memoir right i am
working on water
oh my gosh that's a that's a touchy
subject um
oh man my wife is probably cringing uh
thinking about this because
it's been like not the vein of our
existence but just such a hard thing to
work on
i to be honest never wanted to do a
memoir
i'm no david goggins you know i don't
feel like i have that
crazy passion and fire to like get
people like moving but
yeah but i don't have to tell you you're
a storyteller you have a story to tell
and you know how to tell it but it
doesn't have to be a david goggins story
no no but i think it's just
that's that's my own issue to deal with
right is coming to terms the fact that
that this is something that's important
and i think the only way i've realized
that this is valuable is that coming to
the end of writing that memoir
and realizing that i dealt with so many
self-worth and guilt issues throughout
my life
and learning that i didn't need to hold
on to those and that
and and the conclusions i've came to and
the
the realizations i've came to if that
could help one
young kid boy girl whatever out there
then it's worth it and it's worth the
months and years of time and effort
and collecting these stories and i think
the hard thing is trying to weave my
personal story and journey
throughout these these surf trips and or
explorations and how
they have kind of played a role
supported that um
my relationship um you know and this and
this and that and that's sort of
where i'm at with it so it was supposed
to come out in fall cove it happened
it's been pushed to 2021.
it's kind of right now we're in a
rewrite situation
we're looking at some new editors to
work with to kind of um help
uh formulate just a little bit more
seamless text
so that's where we're at it's exciting
that's exciting i'm excited but i'm just
i'm just nervous like this is your
absolute
most kernel of truth out there for the
world to see
and leave nothing behind and i think
that gives me a little bit of anxiety
it's just a deeper exploration of
vulnerability
you know and it's interesting that
you're consciously aware of how
the process of of writing it is telling
you
who you are like there's a healing for
yourself right from that because you're
it it brings up all of these things that
you kind of are consciously
this is what i'm just i'm i'm i'm
projecting because this was my
experience but yeah
you know it starts to tell you things
about yourself that you weren't
aware of and that's kind of a beautiful
thing yeah
you're you're spot on and maybe the
other way to put it is that
i'm not ready to do that much therapy to
finish the book so
maybe maybe that's what it is um but
we've gotten through it and it's through
a revised
version in a couple of years it's
powerful and i'm grateful and i'm
i'm even i'm even just like humbled that
like somebody a publisher out there
cares
because i'm like yeah cool let's do
another surf book awesome and they're
like no no no we want we want this story
and i'm like
okay and it's also like there's private
aspects of my life where like you know
i'm wanting to like
be careful of how i portray people in my
life and characters in my life and
there's a lot of like
great people maybe some not so great
people and people i've learned from and
experiences i've had and it's just
you're
you're sort of like digging up a lot of
information and trying to make sure that
it all
makes sense and that's a hard process
and i know i know you know it so
right well honesty and storytelling
doesn't mean that it's a tell-all
right those are two different things
right so it's like what is the truth
in my experience that would be helpful
for other people and how do i
how do i you know construct that
narrative without
hurting other people unnecessarily and
this is maybe the exact opposite
of social media where i have to come to
the conclusion
that if people view me at certain
chapters of this book maybe through the
whole thing or in the beginning as an
that's okay
and you have to come to terms with that
and that's like a very hard thing to do
to realize like yeah like there are
decisions or there are things i've done
or there's
whatever that aren't super glamorous and
i think that's just a
it's it's a really healing thing but
it's also like yeah you're putting that
out there well acknowledging that is
is you know humanizing also and i think
when
you know listen a lot of memoirs are are
sort of you know
glossy hero stories but the ones that
that people connect with and that stand
the test of time
are the ones written by people who have
the courage to be vulnerable
and share their story with all their
warts and all yeah
basically you know i think a good way to
close this is just to leave
a few thoughts from your experience or
some wisdom
for the person who's watching or
listening who feels stuck in their life
who
you know maybe isn't living in their car
but is in uh you know kind of in
in a rut or feeling like they're on a
path where their life
doesn't have the meaning or the purpose
that they wish that it would have but
they don't really know how to
um get themselves out of it yeah man
and then ending with a deep one or yeah
hit me with the hard one there um
honestly give me the answer it's yeah um
give me the answer you know it's such a
funny one because i
it's not a matter of if and when you
feel misguided in life or you
feel that a sense of misdirection it's
it's it
it's going to happen right and it's a
cyclical thing i mean i
constantly find myself in that so one of
the things i've considered is like
when i'm on a job when i'm on assignment
when i'm doing what it is i know is
is you know how i you know make a living
i'm giving it 110
115 sometimes maybe even a little more
right
um it's ridiculous how how much i can
focus on work but
the only way i can do that is if when
i'm home or when i have that time for me
that i'm
filling up that well of inspiration i
say it's a well because you're
constantly
taking buckets out of it right for your
friends for this call for a podcast for
this job for this ride around iceland
right that thing is dry
so when i get home it's like what am i
doing to fill myself up what am i doing
to
and you know like it's as easy as like i
could thrust myself back into work
and that would be the easy thing to do
well you could also rationalize that as
what is required for you to fill the cup
yeah exactly but but the truth is it's
not it's it's
now it's learning that hey i'm not going
to wait for mrsa round two to come
around i'm not gonna wait to be thrust
in a jail cell
i'm not i'm gonna i'm gonna allow for
that reflection
from that trip what did i learn from it
you know i just got back
um a week ago from riding through
iceland's interior on this crazy amazing
trip with a handful of canadian cyclists
and
i'm still processing that experience and
i've been giving myself the time
now to process that and digest that and
surround myself with people i care about
only try to take the calls and the
things and do the part that i'm that i'm
inspired by
and ultimately like give yourself a
little grace because
you just spent three four months
training and doing this and hyper
focused then you gave everything you had
and now is time to rebuild so there's a
constant cycle
of giving and rebuilding and i and i've
spent years in my life
being in a situation where i'm just
giving giving giving and i don't mean
like
everybody needs to go out there and get
a mani pedi i'm just saying that at
times
you might want to consider those things
that
that fill you up from a true
deep perspective whether that's faith
whether that's
being out in nature whether that's doing
a little meditation whether that's
taking because for me it's not
photography now it's not picking up the
camera and finding that it's like
i need to kind of get in touch with um
why i did what i did
process it so that i can parlay that
into the next experience so that i can
have a deep understanding of that
experience so i can
really take back the feelings of feeling
so small and insignificant in that big
landscape and
and how can this help somebody else and
i guess in terms of answering your
question of somebody that's
that's looking for you know they're in
this place of a rut like
moving towards that place of discomfort
and i don't mean like head-on
trying to bash your way in to something
i mean like moving towards that place of
discomfort in your life and dealing with
it because that will
open roadblocks that sometimes you
didn't even know were there
your relationship with balance strikes
me as one of
you know a pendulum swinging you know a
wide arc
back and forth right i'm sure people ask
you all the time like how do you
maintain your
work life balance and well i suspect
that terms yeah you don't really think
of it
in the in those terms it's more about
the way i think of it is
is you know how do i live synchronously
in in alignment with my values and
how can i switch gears from being a
hundred percent and one thing to the
next
but the idea of balance like i mean if
you
if you're going to hold me to that
definition like
my life is probably wildly worst example
ever right here
i to be honest this is a term that that
i love and
i talk about all the time with uh with
my wife is like
there's no such thing as balance because
what ends up happening is people come in
and they say hey chris you got married
at 21 you you
have two kids you have this family life
and then you you're traveling for
sometimes six to eight months at a time
yada yada you know and how do you find
balance and i'm like
uh i hate to burst your bubble but
there's no
such thing as balance what we found is
that there is rhythm
and the rhythm is something that
oscillates and sometimes those
waves are bigger and sometimes those
waves are
more finely tuned and they're moving in
kind of a pattern that you can you can
like
comprehend but the truth the matter is
that you're trying to just stay in sync
that's what i'm trying to do i'm trying
to stay in some way on beat
right and what keeps me on beat is
learning how to communicate with my kids
and
remembering what they need they need a
dad who
even if i'm far away i can think of them
i can show them i care
me and my wife have developed a way to
do that so that when i'm
in the middle of nowhere out at the ends
of the earth if i have a sat phone
signal or if i have a supplement i can
think of the things that they care about
or would
want to know here and share that with
them because when i get home
as a parent the very worst thing i could
ever do
is to show up and then them say dad
where have you been
like again the process of becoming a
better person through traveling doesn't
happen when you go there and you get
back it
it starts before you leave your front
door and so for me
i think of them when i go i try to not
just be 115 focused on work but i have a
little space
for them on the road that rhythm is also
found in how
my wife and i balance that relationship
along the road um
faith does play a role in that you know
it it helps if anything
that is the saving grace of what's
really kept us
a family unit in addition to that too
learning and finding that there are
sometimes just more effective ways to
travel does that mean staying an extra
day in your location to like
have a day to chill out after the 60
person 100 person crew leaves and
you're on some wild shoot like is it
better for me to have a day to chill out
so that i come home a more grounded
person
does it mean when i come home i don't go
into the office for a day or two or
three or four
does it mean i there's all these ways to
manage it i think that's kind of one of
the real
tricks that you sort of have to sort out
for yourself and it's such a challenge
because
it varies from person to person and the
one thing i want to say
when it comes to
balancing these relationships or finding
rhythm or whatever is
you know i can come back from the most
wild
you know incredible experience in my
life where i've just been
shown the most beautiful things and and
everything was so real and visceral and
i you know i
who knows what happened and i come home
to my wife and i'm just like or any
person any significant other doesn't
matter
brother sister mom dad whoever
significant other boyfriend girlfriend
and you're just like oh my gosh check
this out let me just dump all this on
you
because i don't know how to process it
i'm just gonna dump all my energy and
emotion
and all this visceralness that i
experienced onto you and that person's
like
they're not a trash can first of all and
they might have been just dealing with
the
doldrums of daily life they might have
been dealing with the diapers they might
have been dealing with some sickness a
family member has they might have
who knows what they've been going on so
what i've found is that sometimes
it requires learning when to hold back
and when to give that amount of
excitement and energy and everything
that i know i can bring to the table
because i can be a fairly excitable
person
at the right time and if there's one
thing i learned
from this process of understanding that
beauty that's out in nature there's a
lot of ways to process it and sometimes
just
spilling it onto another person isn't
the right thing
i try to come home and make sure that
the people in my life
have had their cups full too so that
when we
meet and when there's that time to share
and
energies can be energies hate to say
that term but
it's evenly matched what does that mean
it might mean coming home and supporting
your kids your wife your significant
other and doing something that fills
them up
ultimately it's making sure that this
age-old term of getting outside your
comfort zone is happening on all levels
because if you've just been somewhere
where you've
you've i don't know seen the face of god
whatever you want to call it you've been
outside your comfort zone and you're a
new person
and you come to them that that's grounds
for
usually an altercation i found yeah i
mean that's a great point you know
you you have that enthusiasm and you
want to share it but there's a
selfishness with that too
you know when you're dealing with oh
that's great you're off doing that but
i'm here
you know like i don't really want to
hear it right now a lot of arguments
have started with those words
yeah it's almost like the veteran
who comes back from a tour you know
there's that scene
jeremy renner in that movie and he's
walking down the aisle in the grocery
store
and he's just his eyes are glazed over
and he can't acclimate back to
the normal world there's a unhealthy
kind of addictive
obsessive-compulsive relationship with
adventure
and risk um and i would suspect that
that's something you have to also be
consciously aware of like
is it healthy for me to be doing this at
what point does it tip over
into something that is not serving yeah
like
myself or my family and i think i just
had that experience a week ago when i
was i was in iceland i was one of the
only americans there because i got a
permit to go
and there's no masks and everybody's
tested and
during the duration of our trip there
was no covid it was like i was just like
you're about as socially distant as
a human being could possibly be the
weirdest it was the weirdest thing
because i'm like for a glimpse i would
wake up in the morning and
forget that it existed and i felt
selfish it felt bad i was like oh my
gosh like
and i realized in some way like the only
way maybe i can justify this is to
ultimately make sure i'm sharing this
experience other people
so that they know what life is like and
when i started getting those messages
like from people who are like i'm still
in quarantine
but watching your stories every day has
given me some sense of relief i'm like i
feel so
grateful because i'm not going to not
share i'm not going to not give them
because these updates i give
as much for my own family as for
everybody else so to know that like
there's that hope out there and that the
world can return to normalcy it just
it's a challenging thing but ultimately
coming home and realizing like well
california's on fire and we're wearing
masks then it was it was a little bit of
a shock
felt definitely like seeing a jeremy
renner i've related to that yeah yeah
yeah
yeah cool man well i think that's a good
place to put a pin in it for now and i
say put a pin in it because i want to
continue this conversation with you
uh we could go down the rabbit hole just
on your latest adventure among many
other things
i just i'll process it and then we'll
chat about it whether it's
up on stage at the palace of fine arts
or sitting across from
whatever whatever whatever the world has
in mind for us
but um our history will continue yeah i
appreciate you
yeah um you inspire me
you know obviously you inspire millions
of people but um
i really uh i respect your your art
and what you share with the world but
mostly i respect how you conduct
yourself as a human being and and
i appreciate you and i just thank you
for sharing so openly
and honestly today yeah this was an
honor truly
i'm so grateful thank you um look
forward to the memoir whenever that's
gonna
be done um the movie streaming where can
people check that out when it goes
it's actually going to be available to
the public in october but we're doing a
live
kind of streaming date on september 22nd
i believe you can find all the info on
my
social media channels i'm just going to
basically be doing a sort of a
meet and greet online digitally with the
filmmaker and sort of a
questionnaire about the filmmaking
process and how we made it and
everything so
um yes just catch up on social media
find it
it's a really meaningful story and i
really hope you'll get experience
how do you say it again yeah yeah yeah
you kind of have like that guttural like
yeah yeah it's a
so inner is the name of the doctor in
the language i've learned how to
enunciate like i can say like you know
the english version yeah like
like but it's it's honestly it's close
to spanish because there's a lot of
rolling of ours and things like that
it's a
guttural language it's hard to learn
yeah yeah
well you sound good doing it let's do it
chris burkhart easy to find on the
internet just google them at chris
burkhart everywhere find him on
instagram and
until we meet again my friend thank you
peace
[Music]
you